bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin une
table ronde consacrée à l'apprentissage
dans le cadre des travaux de la
délégation aux entreprises présidé par
la sénatrice les républicains ellisabeth
Lamur l'apprentissage c'est un
dispositif qui permet à des jeunes de
moins de 25 ans d'alterner cours
théorique et période en entreprise c'est
un dispositif jugé efficace pour
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
mais qui souffre d'une image dégradé le
résultat c'est que l'apprentissage est
en constant recul en France ces
dernières années alors quelques chiffres
il y a eu une baisse de 8 % au niveau du
nombre de nouveaux contrats
d'apprentissage en 2013 une baisse de -
3 % encore en 2014 et cela malgré un
nouveau dispositif d'aide prévu par le
gouvernement le gouvernement qui a prévu
une prime de 1000 € supplémentaires pour
les entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
par nouveau contrat d'apprentissage le
recul de l'apprentissage c'est le thème
de la Table Ronde que je vous propose de
voir ce matin une table ronde à laquelle
participent des économistes une
représentante de la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de la stens également un
représentant le président même de
l'assemblée permanente des chambres de
métiers et d'artisanat tout de suite
donc on prend la direction de la salle
médic6 Mesdames et Messieurs les présid
Président mes chers collègues sénateurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
intervenants euh vous n'entendez
pas alors voilà ben je voulais saluer
tout le monde présidente président
sénateur les intervenants qui sont à
cette tribune vous dire que je vous
accueille avec beaucoup de plaisir ce
matin sur un sujet qui est
évidemment passionnant et même passionné
et je vous je vous accueille au titre de
la délégation sénatoriale entreprises
euh qui est donc né en décembre dernier
à l'initiative du président Gérard
Larcher euh qui avait eu l'intuition que
les entreprises avaient le sentiment que
les parlementaires en quelque sorte les
ignoraient un peu euh et ne s'occupaiit
d'ell que pour leur créer des
obligations et des charges
supplémentaires or les entreprises
détiennent pourtant les clés de la
croissance et de l'emploi dans nos
territoires si bien que cette délégation
s'est organisée avec 42 sénateurs qui en
sont membres qui sont viennent
évidemment de tous les groupes
politiques et la délégation a reçu pour
mission de nouer ou de renouer le
dialogue avec les entreprise nous avons
donc choisi d'aller à la rencontre des
entrepreneurs euh sur le terrain pour
les entendre pour mieux les connaître et
depuis le début de l'année nous avons
rencontré une centaine d'entre reprise
euh dans six départements français et
nous sommes également allés à Londres
pour entendre aussi les raisons pour
lesquelles les entreprises françaises
avaient été attirées par une
installation au Royaume-Uni et puis nous
allons continuer à aller encore au
devant des entreprises pour identifier
les freins à leur développement et pour
traduire cela dans notre activité de
législateur euh c'est une démarche qui
participe au renouvellement de l'action
politique que vous le savez on accuse
trop souvent d'être déconnecté des
réalité alors à ce jour nous avons
publié déjà deux rapports pour rendre
publ les enseignements que nous avons
tiré de nos différentes rencontres nous
avons également soutenu des amendements
à l'occasion des projets de loi Macron
et repsamain que nous avons examiné au
printemps dernier et puis nous menons
actuellement des études pour pour
approfondir un certain nombre de sujets
alors nous organisons cette table ronde
aujourd'hui que nous avons nommé
relancer l'apprentissage une urgence
pour les entreprises et pour
l'emploi car en effet après plus de 6
mois de rencontre avec différentes
entrepris donc aux quatre coins de
France nous avons acquis la conviction
que le sujet de l'apprentissage est
majeur à la fois pour l'économie et pour
l'emploi d'ailleurs les entrepreneurs
rencontrés ont particulièrement souligné
leurs difficulté pour recourir à
l'apprentissage alors même que il nous
disaient évidemment combien ils en
avaient besoin l'un d'entre eux nous
disaient par exemple dans la drô que les
compagnons étaient extrêmement précieux
pour son entreprise presque plus que les
ingénieurs parce queils n'ont pas
d'équivalent
ou un autre dénoncé le manque de
souplesse du système de formation en
alternance qui tient à la fois à la
réglementation sur les métiers dangereux
qui empêche de faire effect tuer
certaines tâches aux apprentis de les
former efficacement sur les machines de
l'entreprise donc elle tient aussi à la
rigidité de l'organisation du temps de
travail des apprentis en entreprise à la
quasi impossibilité de rompre le contrat
d'apprentissage si le jeune ne fait pas
l'affaire et puis plus généralement on
sent un défaut de confiance accordé aux
entreprises en France où il semble qu'on
vise davantage à protéger l'apprenti en
quelque sorte de l'abus du patron enfin
tous les entrepreneurs ont déploré
devant nous le manque de valorisation de
l'apprentissage dans le système éducatif
qui tient sans doute au manque de lien
entre l'école et l'entreprise mais
également euh le manque de connaissance
des métiers auxquels forme
l'apprentissage alors c'est sur le
fondement de ces échanges que la
délégation a pu identifier
l'apprentissage comme un défi euh
essentiel euh je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
un jeune sur qu est au chômage c'est un
chiffre alarmant comparativement à
l'Allemagne où où le chômage touche
seulement un jeune sur 14 et chez nous
en France 5,2 % de nos jeunes sont en
apprentissage contre 16 % en Allemagne
et je ne parle pas de la Suisse et on
constate que le nombre d'apprentis en
France va en reculant c'est une baisse
de plus de 10 % en 2 ans que l'on
constate avec les chiffres que nous
communique le gouvernement et sur ce
premier semestre 2015 nous entendons
parler d'un nouveau recul euh qui
traduit cette fois un vrai décrochage de
l'apprentissage dans notre pays et
pourtant ce sont 8,2 milliards d'euros
qui sont consacrés chaque année un
financement qui pèse pratiquement pour
moitié sur les entreprises alors
pourquoi tous ces efforts financiers ne
sont-ils pas couronnés de succès euh
malgré les réformes les modifications
régl réglementaire on voit que
l'apprentissage ne décolle pas et même
qu'il s'effondre alors notre ambition ce
matin à travers les les intervenants qui
sont à cette tribune c'est d'y voir plus
clair de parvenir à dégager des pistes
pour promouvoir l'apprentissage en
entreprise je voudrais donc remercier
les intervenants qui ont accepté de
venir enrichir nos travaux vous
remercier mes chers collègues d'être là
pour
assister à cette rencontre bon qui
s'annonce particulièrement riche euh
notre matinée va s'organiser en deux
temps donc la première table ronde qui
va débuter dans quelques minutes va se
concentrer sur l'analyse des raisons du
recul que connaît l'apprentissage en
entreprise et euh les moyens d'enrayer
ce recul euh la comparaison avec
l'Allemagne à cet égard pourra être
évidemment éclairante et puis pour
compléter cette approche systémique du
sujet euh la seconde table ronde sera
consacrée aux personnes qui font vivre
le système de l'apprentissage par
partout en France donc nous nous
écouterons différents témoignages
d'acteurs de terrain qui viendront
confirmer ou infléchir les analyses ou
les pistes que la première table ronde
nous aura permis de dégager et puis
enfin à l'issue de cette matinée Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat nous fera
l'honneur de venir clore nos travaux
voilà ce que je voulais vous indiquer en
introduction de cette de cette matinée
euh donc nous allons nous avons convié
pour cette première table ronde tout
d'abord deux économistes monsieur
ferrachci et Monsieur Martino de manière
à ce qu'il nous fasse bénéficier de leur
regard éclairé d'universitaire sur le
sujet et nous avons convié madame Dubrac
et Monsieur Griset pour représenter les
chambres consulaires qui occupent
évidemment une place importante sur
l'ensemble du
territoire donc je voudrais laisser la
parole à Monsieur Marc ferci qui est
donc économiste professeur à
l'université Panthéon à SAS euh vous
êtes membre du Conseil d'analyse
économique c'est un organe qui est placé
auprès du premier ministre et qui
réalise je suis pas tout à fait membre
du CEAE j'ai j'ai commis avec d'autres
auteurs une une note sur l'apprentissage
pour le Conseil d'analyse économique je
suis pas officiellement membre du du
Conseil d'analyse économique enfin vous
en êtes très prochein donc je voulais
préciser que c'était un organe qui était
placé auprès du premier ministre et qui
réalisait en toute indépendance
des analyses économiques pour le
gouvernement donc et je précise que vous
avez d'ailleurs à ce titre écrit avec
Pierre cahuk une note intitulée
l'apprentissage au service de l'emploi
c'est bien cela c'est récent c'est en
décembre dernier donc si vous voulez
bien nous présenter ce travail et votre
vision en tout cas du sujet merci à vous
je vous laisse la parole merci madame la
Présidente oui je précise que dans le
prolongement de cette note qui est paru
qui est paru effectivement au début de
l'année début de l'année au conseilal
économique nous avons rédigé avec Pierre
cahuk un ouvrage qui vient de paraître
je crois qu'il paraît aujourd'hui on est
le 1er octobre au presse de Sciences Po
et dont le titre va peut-être d'ailleurs
lancer un petit peu mon mon exposé
s'appelle l'apprentissage donner la
priorité au moins qualifié alors je vais
partir de cette idée-là parce que vous
l'avez bien souligné madame la
Présidente l'apprentissage du point de
vue des effectifs baisse depuis quelques
années en France mais je pense qu'il
faut replacer cette baisse dans une dans
un contexte et dans une tendance plus
générale depuis maintenant 25 ou 30 ans
en tendance les effectifs de
l'apprentissage ont eu tendance à
s'accroître de manière générale et en
réalité il faudrait parler de de
l'alternance au sens large qui cumule à
la fois l'apprentissage et les contrats
de professionnalisation j'y reviendrai
c'est une des caractéristiques de notre
système que d'avoir plusieurs modalités
euh pour finalement un même objectif qui
est de favoriser l'insertion des jeunes
dans l'entreprise alors les effectifs
augmentent mais en réalité cette
augmentation s'est faite principalement
au profit de l'apprentissage dans
l'enseignement supérieur ça c'est le
point sur lequel nous insistons beaucoup
dans les écrits que nous avons réalisé
euh globalement ce la baisse récente que
l'on a pu constater euh s'explique
essentiellement par la baisse de
l'apprentissage dans les bas niveaux de
qualification en particulier au niveau
infrabac c'est-à-dire au niveau CAP et
euh du point de vue de l'analyse
économique le fait que l'apprentissage
se développe plus dans le supérieur
euh pose quelques questions pourquoi
est-ce que cela pose quelques questions
parce que les évaluations
économiques de des formation en
apprentissage les évaluations qui
cherchent à regarder ce que deviennent
les apprentis euh en les comparant à des
jeunes qui auraient des caractéristiques
très similaires et bien montre que
l'apprentissage est un véritable levier
d'insertion professionnelle un levier
puissant mais c'est principalement vrai
pour les bas niveaux de qualification
lorsque vous êtes à bac + 2 ou Bac + 5
la valeur ajoute de l'apprentissage
c'est-à-dire le gain que vous pouvez en
tirer en matière d'insertion
professionnelle durable est finalement
assez faible personnellement j'ai été
j'ai été responsable de formation en
apprentissage à l'université au niveau
Master et c'est vrai que j'ai pu
constater que la la modalité que la
modalité pédagogique que constitue
l'apprentissage par rapport à des stages
longs de fin d'étude n'est pas forcément
n'est pas
forcément porteuse d'une grande grande
valeur ajoutée même si évidemment il y a
des un intérêt à développer
l'apprentissage dans le supérieur mais
ce qu'il faut vraiment ce sur quoi il
faut vraiment insister c'est que pour
les gens du supérieur le diplôme est
lui-même une protection contre le
chômage alors que pour les jeunes les
moins qualifiés et bien il n'y a pas
vraiment d'alternative à l'apprentissage
pour favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle et si on si on
s'intéresse un petit peu aux évolutions
récentes les emplois aidés dans le
secteur non marchand en particulier des
dispositifs comme les emplois jeunes
emplois d'avenir euh ne sont pas une
alternative viable pour favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle durable euh
donc partant de ce constat euh il y a un
certain nombre de bien d'autres constats
et aussi de propositions qui en
découlent mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment vraiment partir de ce point euh
les ressources et plus généralement
l'orientation de notre système
d'apprentissage et je pense que Bertrand
martinau pourra donner un éclairage avec
le le le cas allemand qu'il connaît
extrêmement bien là-dessus je vais pas
trop parler de l'Allemagne parce que
c'est c'est c'est Bertrand le grand
spécialiste de l'Allemagne euh mais
fondamentalement ce que l'on constate
c'est que en Allemagne le nombre
d'apprentis dans l'enseignement
supérieur est proche de zéro alors qu'en
France plus d'un apprentis sur qu est
dans l'enseignement supérieur donc sur
ce sur la base de ce constat on peut
essayer de répondre à la question
pourquoi est-ce que l'apprentissage
baisse euh dans les années récentes euh
je pense qu'il y a des causes qui sont
pour partie conjoncturelles et il y a
des causes beaucoup plus structurelles
qui tiennent au dysfonctionnement de
notre notre système d'apprentissage les
causes conjoncturelles c'est d'abord la
conjoncture elle-même c'est-à-dire le
fait que la croissance est ralentie et
que ça la cela affecte un certain nombre
de secteurs d'activité comme le BTP par
exemple qui sont traditionnellement de
gros utilisateurs d'apprentis ça c'est
un premier élément il a pu dans les dans
les trois ou quatre dernières années se
produire une baisse de l'apprentissage
du fait de décisions politiques qui ont
consisté à réduire les subventions les
subventions aux entreprises en matière
d' apprenti mais ces subventions ont été
rétablies très récemment donc je ne
pense pas que ça constitue désormais la
principale explication à la baisse de
l'apprentissage il a pu également se
produire un phénomène même si on n pas
de preuve statistique de cela il a pu se
produire un phénomène de vase
communiquant entre l'apprentissage et
des dispositifs qui s'adressent au même
public c'est-à-dire aux
jeunes plus ou moins qualifiés tels que
les emplois d'avenir peut-être que les
emplois d'avenir ont entre entre
guillemets cannibaliser un petit peu
certains dispositifs d'apprentissage bon
tout cela ce sont finalement des choses
conjoncturelles qui sont réversibles
dans une certaine mesure mais je pense
que notre système connaît des
dysfonctionnements qui vont au-delà de
ces causes conjoncturelles et sur
lesquels il faut vraiment se pencher si
on veut je ve pas utiliser cette
expression qui qui est un petit peu un
petit peu polémique mais si on veut
inverser durablement la courbe de
l'apprentissage dans notre
pays les les problèmes les problèmes euh
ils sont à la fois
d'ordre financier mais peut-être
principalement d'ordre non financier les
problèmes d'ordre financier je vais pas
m'étendre trop là-dessus c'est que les
subventions qui sont
versées aux apprentis ou plutôt aux
employeurs d'apprentis sont aujourd'hui
trop peu modulés trop peu modulé en
fonction de la qualification comme je
l'ai dit l'apprentissage présente de
grands bénéfices euh pour les jeunes qui
sont sans qualification euh il faut
quand même rappeler que euh la
présidente l'a dit mais je j'en rajoute
on est aujourd'hui en France face à un
phénomène massif il y a 2 millions de
jeunes entre 15 et 29 ans qui ne sont ni
en emploi ni en étude ni en formation
professionnelle ce sont tous les
décrocheurs qui se sont accumulés année
après année et auxquels on a finalement
assez peu de solutions à apporter si ce
n'est si ce n'est des dispositifs comme
l'apprentissage qui mêlent de la
formation avec une insertion dans
l'emploi marchand donc le premier point
encore une fois le premier point c'est
que du point de vue du mécanisme et des
mécanismes de subvention je pense que
l'on gagnerait on gagnerait à mieux
subventionner à donner plus
d'incitations financières aux
entreprises qui embauchent des apprentis
alors il y a un autre aspect qui tient
la présidente l' la l'a évoqué à la
complexité des normes et des contraintes
juridiques qui entourent l'embauche des
apprentis je pense qu'effectivement il y
a de la simplification à apporter à
notre système sur ce point mais il faut
jouer sur les deux levier il faut
limiter les contraintes il faut aussi
donner des incitations et encore une
fois j'insiste les incitations elles
doivent être principalement concentrées
sans forcément évidemment déshabiller
l'apprentissage dans l'enseignement
supérieur mais elles doivent être
principalement concentré vers les bas
niveaux de
qualification à côté de ces de ces
obstacles il y a des obstacles qui
tiennent à la rigidité de notre système
et en particulier la difficulté à
adapter les formations en apprentissage
aux besoins du marché du travail ce que
l'on constate c'est que c'est assez
compliqué d'ouvrir une formation en
apprentissage l'apprentissage donne
droit à un titre donne droit à un
diplôme qui est validé par l'Éducation
nationale et à ce titre l'éducation
nationale joue un rôle important dans la
validation des des formations en
apprentissage en parallèle avec les
région ce que l'on constate c'est que
sans rentrer dans les détails la
procédure qui permet d'ouvrir et de
valider une formation en apprentissage
est assez lourde or ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui de la dynamique du marché du
travail c'est que cette dynamique
s'accélère c'est que de métiers nouveaux
apparaissent par exemple dans le secteur
de l'informatique le besoin en
programmeur en développeur devient
patent et que de ce point de vue le
système éducatif dans son ensemble mais
le système d'apprentissage en
particulier est trop peu agile trop peu
agile donc il faut
euh repenser dans une certaine mesure la
gouvernance de notre système et essayer
de penser le jeu des acteurs de telle
sorte que les entreprises les branches
professionnelles soient véritablement
partie prenantes de l'ouverture des
formations en apprentissage est partie
prenante de la définition de leur
contenu ça j'insiste beaucoup parce que
lorsque l'on se penche très concrètement
sur les contenus des formations au
niveau CAP par exemple qui sont fournis
par l'Éducation nationale et sur le
contenu également des examens et bien on
se rend compte qu'on a des formations
qui sont qui sont souvent très très
éloignées des contenus de formation qui
sont souvent très abstrait euh et très
éloigné des préoccupations des
entreprises alors je n'en fais pas une
généralité euh il y a il y a il y a de
la il y a de la variabilité il y a des
différences il y a de l'hétérogénéité
sur ce point mais de manière générale le
fait que l'éducation nationale soit
véritablement au centre du jeu euh ne me
semble pas ne nous semble pas pierre Kuk
et moi puisqu'on a on a on a développé
ces idéesl dans dans nos ouvrages ne
nous semble pas forcément euh quelque
chose de fertile donc de ce point de vu
remettre les branches et les entreprises
au centre du jeu remettre les
partenaires sociaux également au centre
du jeu comme ils le sont dans d'autres
pays et encore une fois je pense qu'on
pourra parler de l'Allemagne à ce à cet
égard c'est quelque chose c'est quelque
chose de de véritablement de
véritablement très important alors je
vais pas je vais pas monopoliser la
parole je pense que j'aurai l'occasion
de de développer d'autres d'autres
points mais si je résume si je résume
faire en sorte que les moyens
supplémentaires que l'on souhaite
allouer à l'apprentissage aillent
prioritairement au bas niveau de
qualification encore une fois l'idée
c'est pas de déshabiller l'apprentissage
dans l'enseignement supérieur mais de
faire en sorte que ce qui viendra en
plus et bien soit ciblé sur les bas
niveaux de qualification parce que c'est
là que les perspectives d'inser
professionnel sont les plus faibles et
encore une fois il y a peu d'Alternativ
à l'apprentissage faire en sorte que
l'écosystème de l'apprentissage et bien
modifie son centre de gravité pour
donner plus de poids aux branches
professionnels et aux entreprises à la
fois dans dans les décisions d'ouvrir
des formations mais aussi dans la
définition leur contenu ce sont de notre
point de vue les deux priorités du
moment bien merci beaucoup monsieur
ferchci pour avoir également ouvert
cette cette table ronde je vais passer
la parole à Monsieur Berton Bertrand
martinau donc vous êtes également
économiste euh je voulais préciser que
vous aviez été récompensé par le Prix
turgo en 2014 pour votre livre intitulé
chômage inversé la courbe euh vous êtes
l'auteur d'une étude publiée sous le
double timbre du mouvement des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire et
de l'Institut Montaigne et qui
s'intitule l'apprentissage un vaccin
contre le chômage des des jeunes plan
d'action pour la France tirée de la
réussite allemande et vous venz
également de publier un nouvel ouvrage
pour en finir avec le chômage ce qui
marche ce qui ne marche pas chez Fayard
et donc c'est à la fois le lien entre
l'apprentissage et l'emploi et la
comparaison avec l'Allemagne que
nous espérons voir approfondir grâce à
vous je vous laisse la parole bien
volontiers merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la Présidente
alors oui ce qui marche ce qui ne marche
pas sans rentrer dans les
détails l'apprentissage fait partie de
ce qui marche hein donc je rappellerai
pas les les chiffres d'insertion à la
sortie de l'apprentissage je rejoins
tout à fait ce qu' a dit Marc
ferci moi l'apprentissage le
développement de l'apprentissage dans le
supérieur ne me pose aucun problème
c'est très bien bien c'est c'est parfait
c'est c'est voilà sauf que c'est pas là
que se pose le problème de l'insertion
de l'insertion donc donc effectivement
c'est c'est vers c'est B niveau de
qualification c'est premiers niveau de
qualification qu'il faut faire porter
l'effort mais ça ne veut pas dire du
tout que le développement de
l'apprentissage dans supérieur soit une
mauvaise chose bien entendu alors pour
je vais axer pas mal mon intervention
donc sur la la comparaison avec
l'Allemagne mais déjà je voudrais
revenir un tout petit peu sur le
pourquoi le l'apprentissage recule en
France alors Marc a commencé à en parler
je vais insister un petit peu il y a
effectivement la concurrence des emplois
d'avenir puisque en fait on on s'adresse
à peu près au même public c'est-à-dire
des jeunes peu peu diplômés peu
qualifier donc c'est évident mais
au-delà il y a clairement d'un point de
vue conjoncturel il y a un il y a eu un
désintérêt du gouvernement pendant les
les deux premières années on va dire ce
qui veut dire
que le gouvernement et puis tout le tout
l'appareil administratif j'en parle en
connaissance de cause puisque j'ai été
pendant quelques années Déqué général à
l'emploi et la formation professionnelle
au minist ministère de l'Emploi quand
vous mobilisez toute la toute la sphère
publique sur un
objectif par définition vous le
mobilisez pas sur autre chose donc
depuis 2012 il faut savoir que les
services de l'État au sens large ont été
et le service public de l'emploi été
totalement mobilisé sur les emplois
d'avenir et donc les journées n'ayant
que que 24 heur et ben pendant ce
temps-là vous ne vous préoccupez moins
évidemment de sujet de tel de type
apprentissage donc ça veut dire très
concrètement que l'éducation nationale
ne s'est pas mobilisé sur
l'apprentissage ces dernières années ça
veut dire que le service public de
l'emploi au sens large ver pour l'emploi
mais surtout les missions locales n'ont
pas été mis sous tension sur
l'apprentissage c'estd qu'on leur a
demandé de faire des emplois d'avenir
essentiellement euh les les régions euh
on va en reparler mais les régions n'ont
pas été non plus incitées par le
gouvernement à tel point que le
gouvernement en 2014 a retiré le dernier
outil que l'État avait pour inciter les
régions à aller vers l'apprentissage qui
étaiit des conventions d'objectif des de
moyens qui faisait dépendre des
subventions des dotations budgétaires
aux régions euh d'un certain nombre
d'atteint d'objectifs en matière
d'apprentissage donc ça ça a été
débranché euh et donc en fait il y a
plus de véritablement de de
pilotageapprentissage alors les les
chiffres ont tellement baissés ça a été
rappelé notamment sur les premiers
niveaux de qualification je rappelle que
sur l'année 2014 il y a eu une petite
augmentation du nombre d'apprentis dans
le supérieur mais une baisse beaucoup
plus forte que la moyenne dans les
premiers niveaux de qualification alors
voilà pour les aspects conjoncturels
alors maintenant je rejoins tout à fait
ce que dit Marc c'est pas parce que ce
qui passe depuis 3 ans en matière
d'apprentissage est assez catastrophique
que tout allait bien avant en fait ça
fait de très nombreuses années que les
différents gouvernements essayent de
relancer l'apprentissage généralement en
remettant de l'argent au pot hein en
doublonnant éventuellement ce que font
les régions en créant de nouvelles aides
et cetera et pourtant
l'apprentissage a peu progressé depuis
2004 en tout cas pas du tout au en
proportion des moyens supplémentaires
qui ont été affectés et puis cette
progression a eu lieu exclusivement dans
les niveaux supérieurs encore une fois
elle a elle a stagné voire un petit peu
diminué selon les années sur les niveaux
cap et bac professionnel et en fait le
problème c'est que un des problèmes
importants de l'apprentissage en France
c'est que il est à un bon niveau au
niveau CAP au niveau Bac Professionnel
ça n'a pas pris hein c'est-à-dire que 80
% des bâeliers professionnels préparent
le bac professionnel en lycée
professionnel et non pas en
apprentissage alors donc le problème il
est pas évidemment con
alors c'est pour ça que ça ça ça renvoie
à une comparaison avec d'autres pays
alors la présidente a rappelé que il y a
plusieurs pays qui ont de très très
bonnes performances en matière
d'apprentissage et c'est pas par hasard
c'est exactement les mêmes pays qui ont
de très bonnes performance en matière
d'insertion de l'emploi que vous le
quels que soient les chiffres que vous
preniez que vous preniez le taux
d'emploi le taux de chômage le taux
d'insertion à 6 mois après le diplôme
enfin vous prenez ce que vous voulez ces
pays font mieux en que la France en
matière de chômage et c'est évidemment
pas de chômage des jeunes et c'est
évidemment pas un hasard alors moi je me
suis pour des raisons personnelles je
linguistique je me suis concentré sur
l'Allemagne non pas parce que
l'Allemagne est peut-être le meilleur
pays c'est pas ça je pense que la Suisse
est fait au moins aussi bien voire voire
peut-être mieux mais que voulez-vous
l'Allemagne c'est le pays dont on est le
plus proche et celui que N a lesquels
nos entreprises ont le plus de de de
contact donc c'était quand même
intéressant d'aller voir ce que fait
l'Allemagne qui est euh une réussite sur
sur ce sujet alors pour illustrer la
réussite allemande par rapport à la
France dans dans l'étude que j'ai faite
pour la pour l'Institut
Montaigne je résume ça la règle des 33
la proportion d'apprentis en Allemagne
est trois fois plus élevée hein donc en
proportion he pas en nombre absolu en
nombre absolu aussi mais ce qui compte
c'est la proportion le taux de chômage
des jeunes de donc de 16 à 25 ans est
trois fois plus élevé en France et on le
dit pas assez parce que il fallait aller
regarder de près les les chiffres le le
coût par jeune pour les finances
publiques et par an est trois fois
supérieur en France voilà je parle des
finances publiques je je dis pas ce que
fait mais par ailleurs les entreprises à
Taxe d'Apprentissage bien entendu et je
reviendrai les entreprises allemandes
payent beaucoup plus pour
l'apprentissage que la France qui
sursubventionne par les finances
publiques donc on a un système qui sans
rentrer vraiment dans les détails juste
en regardant un petit peu et quand même
assez peu efficace en France puisque
vous avez beaucoup moins d'apprentis en
proportion et vous mettez beaucoup plus
d'argent par an et par
apprenti de de denier public
voilà alors le la la dernière chose qui
est très frappante avec l'Allemagne
c'est que l'apprentissage en Allemagne
est développé aussi bien dans la plus
petite entreprise de moins de 5 salariés
que dans chez Volkswagen oui aussi chez
Deutsche Bank et cetera c'est-à-dire que
en Allemagne quelle que soit la taille
de l'entreprise vous avez à peu près 5 5
et demi 6 % selon des strat de salariés
qui sont apprentis alors qu'en France
l'apprentissage vous savez est pour la
moitié des apprentis sont des
entreprises de moins 10 ce qui veut dire
c'est quelque chose de très très
important ça veut dire que l'image de
l'apprentissage est très différente en
France dans l'Allemagne pour cette
raisonl typiquement quand vous voyez des
des parents par exemple l'apprentissage
c'est l'image de l'APEN de l'apprenti
c'est l'apprenti boulanger alors bien
entendu il y a pas que il y a pas que
des apprentis boulangers en France vous
avez aussi des apprentis dans des écoles
d'ingénieurs des écoles de commerce vous
avez de l'apprentissage au niveau du bac
professionnel des licences
professionnelles vous en avez partout
des apprentis mais c'est vrai que
statistiquement cette image est tout à
fait fondée statistiquement la plus
grande proportion des apprentis en
France sont dans les capap dans des
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés
c'est la réalité statistique alors qu'en
Allemagne quand vous parlez d'apprenti
bah l'apprenti en Allemagne l'apprenti
typique c'est le gars qui vend des
voitures dans un concessionnaire chez un
concessionnaire c'est votre employé de
banque euh c'est c'est un technicien
chez Siemens c'est c'est ça l'apprenti
en Allemagne c'est beaucoup les services
puisque l'apprentissage en Allemagne
contrairement ce qu'on pourrait pensé
est plus développé dans les services que
dans la que dans l'industrie en
proportion voilà donc vous avez cette
image qui est très différente c'est ça
en fait la qui fait la la réussite
allemande l'apprentissage est partagé à
tous les niveaux d'entreprise et de
secteur d'activité alors pourquoi euh
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que
la l'Allemagne réussit mieux que la
France dans ce domaine alors très
souvent on lit que c'est c'est la
culture c'est culturel voilà que
voulez-vous bah oui les Allemands sont
pas fabriqués comme nous ils ont pas la
même culture voilà c'est comme ça et bon
alors euh c'est un peu court évidemment
bon il a échappé personne que les
Allemands sont pas comme nous ils sont
plus grands et cetera bon ils sont plus
nombreux plus vieux bon bref mais non
c'est il faut rester sérieux bien sûr
qu'il y a des dimensions culturelles
mais il y a un moment faut regarder les
chif il faut regarder les systèmes
juridique il faut regarder le
financement les circuits de financement
faut regarder comment tout ça est
organisé et cetera faut regarder quelles
sont les incitations après tout
l'entrepreneur allemand il est comme le
français il veut maximiser son profit il
veut reculer recruter des talents il il
veut faire survivre son entreprise il
veut se développer être plus compétitif
que ses concurrents et cetera donc
fondamentalement il raisonne à peu près
pareil alors ensuite effectivement la
culture allemande du Meister qui remonte
au Moyen-âge et cetera on peut écrire
des des milliers de pages sur le sujet
mais il y a quand même des choses très
très concrètes alors quatre différences
euh qui font que le modèle allemand le
modèle économique de l'apprentissage en
Allemagne est très très très très
différent alors la première la plus
évidente c'est que l'apprentissage est
une voie obligatoire pour l'accès à 330
métiers voilà qui sont de niveau bac
professionnel en fait puisque le
l'apprentissage en Allemagne c'est
exclusivement bac professionnel il y a
pas de cap il y a pas dans le supérieur
enfin il y a des choses qui existent
dans le supérieur vous' inquiétez pas
les étudiants allemands font des stages
des stages longs font des choses qui
ressemblent un peu à l'apprentissage
mais c'est pas le même système c'est
qu'il y a pas le même encadrement
juridique le tuteur et tout le et tout
le système qui qui va bien alors donc ça
veut dire que là où en France dans la
quasittalité des métiers du niveau Bac
Pro vous avez le choix entre la voie
scolaire lycée professionnel et
l'apprentissage en Allemagne c'est
exclusivement l'apprentissage voilà il
pas le choix donc déjà ça vous explique
mécaniquement euh pourquoi l'Allemagne
fait plus d'apprentis le deuxième le
deuxième sujet il est organisationnel
c'est que l'organisation administrative
en Allemagne est beaucoup plus claire et
la la répartition des responsabilités
est beaucoup plus évidente pour résumer
et je je le connais évidemment bien pour
avoir été à la tête de ce de
l'administration de ce du ministère de
l'emploi en France personne ne peut
véritablement répondre à la question
l'apprentissage baisse de depuis 3 ans
c'est la faute à qui moi je peux vous
écrire que c'est la faute du
gouvernement je peux aussi vous faire
toute une dissertation pour vous
expliquer que c'est à cause des régions
je peux aussi vous dire que c'est à
cause d'un certain nombre de branches et
d'entreprise qui ne jouent pas le jeu
voilà la vérité c'est que c'est un peu
la faute à tout le monde et la faute à
personne quand c'est la faute à tout le
monde en général c'est la faute à
personne en Allemagne il y a un pilotage
et c'est ça qui est extraordinaire c'est
que l'Allemagne est un pays beaucoup
plus décentralisé que la France mais
avec un pilotage central beaucoup plus
fort et il ne faut pas se faire
d'illusion autant l'Allemagne est un
pays fédéral ce qui veut dire que des
compétences essentielles sont fédérées
des compétences de police des
compétences toute l'éducation il y a pas
l'éducation nationale toute l'éducation
la formation tout est régionalisé pour
autant en matière d'emploi et en matière
de formation professionnelle et en
matière d'apprentissage il y a un
pilotage central donc les Allemands ont
trouvé des compromis institutionnels qui
fait que globalement il y a un pilote de
l'avion il y a du reporting statistique
il y a du pilotage ça marche
effectivement beaucoup mieux le service
public de l'emploi est beaucoup plus
impliqué et le service public de
l'emploi je rappelle est piloté par le
Boon
et pas par les lender donc on se fait
beaucoup d'idées fausses sur l'Allemagne
souvent trème 3oème chose très
importante la formation et les diplômes
sont beaucoup plus axés sur le métier
moins sur les matières générales et il y
a beaucoup moins de temps passé
matériellement en CFA ce qui permet au
passage de rendre le modèle économique
plus rentable pour les entreprises parce
que les apprentis passent beaucoup plus
de temps dans l'entreprise en Allemagne
qu'en France alors je vais juste vous
lire pour expliquer les grands principes
je vais vous lire un extrait du Code du
travail français qui va vous qui va vous
donner donner les objectifs de
l'apprentissage en France il a pour
objet de donner à des jeunes
travailleurs ayant satisfait à
l'obligation scolaire une formation
générale théorique et pratique en vue de
l'obtention d'une qualification
professionnelle sanctionnée par un
diplôme donc l'objectif c'est d'avoir
une qualification professionnelle
sanctionnée par un diplôme la loi
allemande dit transmettre les
compétences connaissances et capacités
professionnelles nécessaires à
l'exercice d'une activité professionnel
qualifié dans un monde du travail en
mutation tout est dit c'estàdire que sur
les principes généraux de la loi les
objectifs sont un peu différents bien
sûr dans dans les deux cas on parle de
qualification professionnelle mais dans
un cas c'est l'obtention d'un diplôme de
l'autre c'est acquérir des compétences
dans un monde en mutation dernière
dernière différence la beaucoup plus
forte implication des branches et des
entreprises qui sont comme l'a dit Marc
au cœur du système en Allemagne et qui
sont un peu
disons en marge en France ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les branches en
Allemagne interviennent beaucoup plus
qu'en France dans le contenu des
enseignements alors qu'en France elles
sont largement marginalisées par
l'Éducation nationale les branches
s'occupe de l'organisation enfin les
branches les les chambres consulaires
s'occupent de l'organisation des examens
et enfin elles organisent un tutorat qui
est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus structuré en Allemagne autour donc
du titre de Meister en Allemagne auquel
est attaché des rémunérations
spécifiques une reconnaissance
professionnelle très forte des
évolutions de carrière plus favorables
et cetera donc on est dans un système
qui est assez fondamentalement différent
pour autant je continue de penser c'est
pour ça que dans dans mon ouvrage
j'essaie de d'en déduire d'en déduire ce
qu'on pourrait transcrire en France et
je pense que tout n'est pas que culturel
et je pense qu'il y a un certain nombre
de réformes qu'on peut faire en
particulier sur la place relative de
l'éducation nationale de l'entreprise et
des régions qui pourrait parfaitement se
faire sur quelques années en France sans
pour autant bousculer les cultures les
habitudes et cetera je pense qu'on peut
faire pas mal de choses en s'inspirant
du du modèle allemand voilà c'était à ça
que je voulais en en arriver merci
beaucoup et bien merci beaucoup pour
tout ce que vous nous avez appris à la
fois les les les vraies idées les
fausses idées et cette comparaison que
l'on évoque extrêmement souvent avec
notre voisin alors nous allons passer
maintenant aux chambres consulaire donc
madame Danielle Dubrac vous êtes
vice-présidente de de la CCI de scè
Saint-Denis et et vous parlez ici au nom
de la CCI région Île-de-France et
également de l'ensemble des du réseau
des CCI vous êtes également membre du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental donc ce que nous vous
proposons c'est de que vous nous donniez
l'analyse des CCI sur le recul de
l'apprentissage en France nous indiquer
quelle piste à votre niveau vous
entrevoyez pour promouvoir
l'apprentissage dans les entreprises de
notre pays je vous laisse la la parole
merci beaucoup merci de cette initiative
et surtout merci de de s'intéresser au
sujet parce que le développement de
l'apprentissage pour nous c'est vraiment
la clé de la réussite de de nos jeunes
dans nos écoles il faut savoir que
au-delà de l'appui réglementaire au-delà
de la transmission des entreprises
création d'entreprise et cetera les
chambres considèrent que le
l'apprentissage est un engagement
prioritaire pour elle tout simplement
parce qu'on est en train de former les
personnes qui vont être dans nos
entreprises il faut que vous sachiez
avant peut-être qu'on fasse quatre
préconisations que nous représentons le
premier réseau de de de personnes qui
qui forment des apprentis en France avec
nos 141 CFA on forme 100000 apprentis
100000 apprentis c'est un/4 des
apprentis formés en France et il y a une
progression des effectifs formés par les
CCI alors c'est vrai que malheureusement
depuis 2013 on sent qu'il y a une chute
des apprentis formés hein hein c'est - 7
% entre 2013 et 2015 c'est vrai que dans
nos CFA c'est moins que la moyenne
nationale il faut peut-être dire en
préambule et en préalable que pour nous
on considère que l'apprentissage n'est
pas un mode de lutte contre le chômage
en tant que tel ni un mode un outil lié
à l'emploi mais plutôt un mode
d'apprendre on est en train de parler de
formation initiale en alternance il faut
aussi remarquer au niveau de son
histoire de l'apprentis
tout simplement que quand l'économie va
mal l'apprentissage va mal c'est
statistiquement reprouvable dans nos CFA
on a 63 % des des apprentis formés qui
préparent un CAP ou un bac professionnel
et on a une volonté constante de former
dans une filière c'est quelqu'un qui va
commencer par un c un cap va pouvoir
peut-être aller à un bac + 5 on n'est
pas on n'est pas en train d'opposer les
niveau supérieur ou niveau inférieur
simplement ça doit correspondre aux
besoins des entreprises et souvent dans
une filière on peut commencer par un cap
et terminer par des diplômes plus élevés
dans l'enseignement supérieur donc en ce
qui concerne l'accompagnement des
chambres il faut dire aussi une chose
c'est que le taux de réussite aux
examens ou d'insertion professionnelle
est supérieur à 83 % c'est vrai qu'au
niveau de la moyenne nationale c'est 70
% mais il faut aussi dire qu'il y a tout
un accompagnement il y a la relation
entre le jeune et l'entreprise et
l'organisme de formation qui est le CFA
et tout ça c'est vrai que ça ça coûte du
temps de l'énergie et ça fait aussi ça
contribue à la réussite de de
l'entreprise et aussi du jeûne et les
taux de rupture des contrats sont de 11
% au niveau de la moyenne nationale nous
on a salué l'engagement du président de
la République sur ces sur ces aspects là
et on salue vraiment l'initiative que
vous avez aujourd'hui donc on offre un
service complet aux entreprises il faut
que vous sachiez qu'on enregistre 145000
contrats d'AP apprentissage c'estàdire
ça correspond à un contrat sur deux et
ça fonctionne bien c'est une mission de
service public que nous a confié l'État
en 2005 on enregistre aussi 350000
dossiers de taxes d'apprentissage que
l'on reverse à plus de 18000
établissement alors nous qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour l'apprentissage et bien on
organise des manifestations on essaie
d'être pragmatique pour l'entreprise on
essaie d'être près de l'entreprise et
donc on organise des actions nationales
qui sont déclinées localement de
promotion apprentissage pour essayer
d'enrayer cette baisse qu'on observe
comme vous depuis 2013 on organise par
exemple en mai 2015 on a organisé la
semaine de l'apprentissage donc ce sont
des manifestations qui se font en local
qui sont organisées sur l'ensemble du
territoire et qui favorise tout
simplement la rencontre des jeunes avec
les entreprises et du coup cette année
par exemple on a contacté 100000
entreprises il faut aussi savoir qu'en
ce qui concerne la mobilisation des
entreprises et ça ça fonctionne vraiment
il y a des développeurs de
l'apprentissage alors ils sont payés par
différents entités nous on en a 100 dans
notre organisation qui sont sur le
terrain il faut que vous sachiez que
c'est 100 développeurs de
l'apprentissage qui ont donc expliqué ce
que c'est que l'apprentissage qui ont
accompagné qui ont contacter elles ont
réissu depuis 2009 à contacctter 220000
entreprises et surtout à signé 55
contrats qui ont été décrochés mais sur
ces 55000 55000 pardon contrat décrochés
il faut que vous sachiez que 60 % des
entreprises qui sont qui ont été
concernées à ce moment-là n'avaient
jamais utilisé le système de
l'apprentissage ce qu'on peut dire aussi
c'est que il faut effectivement stopper
cette chute des effectifs nous on a
toujours alerté le gouvernement qui soit
n'importe quel type de gouvernement on a
toujours soutenu les politiques
publiques en faveur du développement de
l'apprentissage mais c'est vrai que par
rapport aux différentes réformes bien
entendu la réforme de en ce qui concerne
la collecte de la tque d'apprentissage
c'est vrai qu'il y a une grosse
difficulté par exemple nous en ce qui
concerne la taxe qui qui est reversée au
niveau des CCI entre 2014 et 2015 c'est
- 18 % par rapport à la à la répartition
actuelle ce recul historique ça tient au
problème de financement mais ça tient
aussi et vous l'avez dit à une
insuffisance de valorisation de la voie
de l'apprentissage au niveau des jeunes
et au niveau de l'orientation ça ça
tient aussi se recule à la révision à la
baisse des aides on va en parler et à
l'insécurité financière dans lequelle on
est c'estàdire qu'en fait il y a
toujours il y a une réglementation et
puis quelques temps plus tard il y a une
autre réglementation on est quand même
dans une insécurité au regard aussi des
nouvelles règles d'affectation là il y a
une nouvelle règle pour 2015 mais il
faut savoir aussi qu'en ce qui concerne
la taxe d'apprentissage en 2016 avec les
les OPC nationaux il va y avoir aussi
une nouvelles règles d'affectation donc
quand le gouvernement a organisé au mois
de mai une table ronde sur cet aspect-là
on a dit qu'il fallait faire un plan
d'urgence sur l'apprentissage et donc on
a tout simplement orienté nos
propositions sur quatre axes le premier
axe c'est de convaincre les jeunes
d'aller à l'apprentissage et bien
entendu convaincre les jeunes bah ça
veut dire que il faut absolument que
cette voie de l'apprentissage ne soit
pas perçue comme une voie secondaire
mais bien une voix qui correspond à
aller vers un métier aller vers une
filière et finalement à terme trouver un
emploi mais un emploi qui soit en
adéquation avec les besoins des
entreprises au niveau des CCI quand il y
a une section qui correspond pas à
besoin d'une entreprise et ben on ferme
la section hein on n'est pas et quand on
a un besoin qui correspond aux
entreprise on va ouvrir une section avec
la difficulté bien entendu qu'il y a au
niveau de des titres et et de
l'obtention à l'inscription rencp de nos
titres il y a aussi une difficulté parce
que il faut bien sûr au-delà de
l'instruction du dossier et au-delà de
la période de 3 ans
de de de de de provisoire de de ces
titres il faut aussi qu'il ait pas une
lutte et qu'on nppose pas dans certains
cas de figure l'éducation nationale à
les autres organisme de formation alors
sur la sur convaincre au niveau des
jeunes et bien il faut donner aux jeunes
et aux familles une information complète
sur ces formation et ses débouchés bah
par exemple on pourrait rendre
obligatoire la participation de tous les
collèges en a au moins une session de
découvert de l'apprentissage de type
mercredi d'apprentissage nous tous nos
CFA tous les mercredis après-midi ils
sont ouverts pour expliquer ce que c'est
que nos formations et ce que c'est que
l'apprentissage ça correspond à à 3000
initiatives toute l'année sur cet
aspect- là on pourrait aussi généraliser
l'accès sur tout le territoire au
ministage de découvertees professionnell
pendant les vacances scolaires au-delà
bien entendu de cette fameuse semaine
d'observation qui a lieu en 3e et puis
il faut vraiment vraiment culturellement
et symboliquement stopper la
dévalorisation de l'apprentissage dans
le système d'orientation il faut
vraiment introduire l'apprentissage dans
les choix d'orientation de la procédure
d'affectation des élèves post- 3e de
collège voilà il faut que ça soit un
système qui soit automatique qu'on
propose l'apprentissage sur le deuxième
aspect j'en ai encore deux après la
mobilisation des entreprises bon bah ça
la mobilisation des entreprises nous
évidemment on est très proche de
l'entreprise donc on essaie de de de la
de la de les convaincre de la valeur
ajoutée de l'apprentissage quand elles
ont un apprenti elles sont convaincues
mais parce que elles estiment que quand
elles ont un apprenti c'est du
prérecrutement c'est un maintien des
savoir-fire dans l'entreprise mais il y
a des freins il y a des frein il y a le
coût à l'embauche ça coûte quand même de
l'argent à l'entreprise même si ça coûte
pas des salaires mais ça coûte voilà il
faut aussi qu'il y ait des tuteurs qui
soient formés il faut la relation avec
l'organisme de formation il y a un
manque d'adéquation des fois entre la
formation suivie avec les besoins de
l'entreprise et puis il y a la lourdeur
administrative alors c'est vrai qu'au
niveau des chambres on a nos nos on a
nos portails on a toute une un suivi en
ligne des des questions que peuvent
poser les entreprises sur C cette
complexité mais si on pouvait rendre un
peu moins indigeste cet aspect là ce
serait quand même bien après vous savez
il y a la notion de niveau il y a la
notion d'âge et notion de secteur tout
ça si on pouvait simplifier ça serait
bien donc l'action des développeurs en
apprentissage nous on a vu on vous l'a
dit mais on le redit ça a clairement
démontré son efficacité tout simplement
parce qu'on est là à expliquer à
l'entreprise que c'est important euh je
rappelle 220000 entreprises qui ont été
contactées depuis 2009 et 55000 contrat
décroché avec des entreprises qui
n'avaient jamais recruté des apprentis
alors on s'étonne quand même d'un
certain nombre
de modification hein sur la le
financement sur le financement nous on
s'étonne que les entreprises entre 11 à
250000 salariés qui sont vraiment un
gisement d'emploi en France c'est
vraiment ces entreprisesl qui
correspondent à à à aux besoin
d'apprentis enfin aux possibilités de
recrutement des apprentis parce que ces
entreprises es représentent à peu près
40 % de l'effectif salariés en France et
aujourd'hui statistiquement il y a que
moins de 30 % d'apprentis dans ces
entreprises donc elles doivent être
visées et là ces entreprises là comme
par hasard elles sont excluses des
mesures de de incitation financière au
recrutement alors on pourrait donner
comme proposition sur ce sujet-là j'en
ai deux c'est ouvrir aux entreprises de
11 à 250 B peut-être 50 salariés qui
accèdent pour la première fois à
l'apprentissage ou celle qui recrutent
un apprenti supplémentaire on pourrait
leur donner une aide du dispositif
apprentissage à coup zéro la fameuse
aide qu'on donne de 4400 € au moins de
11 salariés il faut aussi simplifier le
contrat d'AP tissage bon ça je l'ai dit
il faudrait c'est un peu indigeste il
faudrait réduire le nombre de rubriques
du formulaire SERFA et puis aussi au
niveau de la rupture du contrat hein la
rupture du contrat quand c'est une
rupture définitive quand c'est pas un
abandon des fois il y a des abandons les
jeunes ont trouvé un emploi to ils
abandonnent avant la fin du contrat non
je parle des ruptures définitives il
faudrait simplifier le le les condition
de la procédure de rupture et peut-être
éviter ou au moins limiter le passage et
l'intervention du Conseil des prudomes
et il faut valoriser le tutorat c'est
extrêmement important le tutorat d'abord
c'est la transmission du savoir et du
savoir-faire dans l'entreprise et euh
c'est quelque chose qui fait le lien
entre le CFA et euh et le jeune et donc
il faudrait inscrire à l'inventaire des
compétences nationales les titres de
tuteur et de maître d'apprentissage les
chambres forment les maîtres
d'apprentissage et les tuteurs sur sur
leur leur mission justement de de de de
maîtrre de Teura et il faudrait associer
plus systématiquement les maîtres
d'apprentissage à la validation du
diplôme sur le troisième point c'est le
point important c'est le nerf de la
guerre c'est le financement de
l'apprentissage aujourd'hui on est dans
une insécurité de ce financement on a
alerté depuis des mois sur le risque de
financement insuffisant il faut que vous
sachiez que les 63 % des entreprises
aujourd'hui sont des entreprises de
petite taille et donc elles ne
participent même pas à la taille
apprentissage hein du fait de qu'elles
sont de petite taille elles n'ont pas
d'obligation de verser la taxe ça c'est
un point important ça veut dire que il y
a d'autres entreprises qui vont
collecter finalement pour pour celle-ci
la réforme de la taxe d'apprentissage
qui a été initiée en 2014 ben elle
génère des incertitudes et je vous parle
pas de 2016 euh quant au maintien du
niveau du
CFA par exemple en Île-de-France il y a
la moitié des CFA qui ont qui ont des
difficultés par rapport à cette cette
taxe alors que on a on est bien
conscient queon veut développer cet
apprentissage donc on fait on fait part
de cette crainte et puis bon on va pas
opposer les les les postbac et les
infrabac mais le développement de
l'apprentissage il se fait aujourd'hui
sur ces niveaux-là bon il y a des par
exemple en île-de-fance on a besoin de
Bachelor parce que ça correspond au
besoins des entreprises donc voilà donc
on forme dans des classes d'ingénieur ou
dans des classes de de commerce ben on
forme des des gens qui sont utiles aux
entreprises et on constate que pour ce
qui est des niveaux postbac ce
développement est freiné par le manque
de moyens financiers par exemple à
différents établissements publics les
CFA du supérieur ne bénéficient pas
systématiquement de l'appui des conseils
régionaux ou bien alors leure rémunéré
n'est pas de même nature que celle de
niveau plus bas donc on propose quoi on
propose d'assouplir les conditions
d'affectation de la taxe d'apprentissage
pour offrir plus de liberté aux
entreprises c'est quand même l'argent
des entreprises et et leur permettre
notamment de permettre notamment aux
organismes collecteurs d'allouer en tant
que besoin du hors Côa vers
l'apprentissage et puis on propose de
sécuriser et de stabiliser le
financement d'apprentissage dans le
supérieur c'est-à-dire traiter à parité
le financement des formations
supérieures en apprentissage hein dans
l'université il y a des dotations et
bien on pourrait peut-être imaginer
d'instituer une obligation de
financement des établissements
supérieurs c'est-à-dire je parle des bac
+ 3 à bac + 5 privé et conu à la charge
des régions ou de l'État à l'instar du
du moyen sympa qui est appliquable aux
universités sinon ben on sera obligé de
solliciter une participation des
apprentis au financement de leur
formation c'est aussi une possibilité
qui pourrait être une possibilité voilà
sinon la dernière le dernier point et on
va rejoindre les personnes qui ont déjà
parlé c'est la consolidation de la
gouvernance régionale on représente les
entreprises on on on on recrute et on
n'est pas dans la gouvernance régionale
euh tout ça parce que bon il y a eu un
certain nombre de réglementation qui est
arrivée et bien entendu on a conféré aux
régions la responsabilité d'arrêter les
cartes régionales des formations
professionnelles initiales et donc là
les partenaires sociaux sont consultés
les chambres de commerce sont écartés
les chambres consulaires sont sont
écartés les représentants du monde
économique sont exclus du débat alors
que c'est elles-mêm quand même qui
doivent pouvoir savoir quels sont les is
qui qui partent quels sont les emplois
qui reviennent quels sont les besoins
quelles sont les qualités de formation
quelles sont les insertions ce qui fait
que sur le plan opérationnel ben il y a
aucun texte aujourd'hui qui ne prévoit
d'instance régional dédié à
l'apprentissage où l'ensemble des
acteurs pourrai se parler de façon
formelle elle pourrait se retrouver
l'ensemble des acteurs pour nous c'est
bien sû l'État c'est bien sur la région
c'est bien sur les branches c'est aussi
les consulair c'est les organismes de
formation donc ça ça correspond ce sont
des freins ce sont des freins
institutionnels qui doivent être
absolument euh levés et qu'il faudrait
qu'on aille vers un dispositif et un
processus de codécision donc vous avez
des le le le service public de de
régional de l'orientation le Spro
pourquoi ne pas imaginer de créer un
spra un service public régional de
l'apprentissage ça pourrait être un lieu
de dialogue ça pourrait être un lieu
d'échange de bonnes pratiques et de
problématiques sur l'apprentissage ça
pourrait aussi être un lieu d'une
politique régionale et d'action de
promotion sur ce sujet-là euh à
l'ensemble des acteurs et puis bah voilà
on pourrait imaginer dans un premier
temps faire un plan de dém démarchage
coordonné vers les entreprises par que
les entreprises elles ont besoin d'être
contacté une fois mais pas 50 fois pour
identifier des opportunités sur le
contrat d'apprentissage je vous remerci
de votre
attention bien merci madame de nous
avoir donné le point de vue des
entreprises sur le sujet et nous allons
poursuivre avec Alain grriiset qui est
le président de la PCM une institution
que tout le monde connaît et qui je
crois fête son 90e anniversaire voilà
donc si vous pouvez nous donner le point
de vue des chambres de métiers à la fois
sur la situation actuelle de
l'apprentissage et puis surtout sur les
pistes que vous proposer pour tenter de
relancer l'apprentissage en
France bien merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
peut-être au début de cette intervention
euh deux éléments bon tout le monde le
sait monsieur Martino par ce qu'il a dit
sur l'image que les Français se faisait
de l'apprentissage en disant que c'était
l'apprenti boulanger confirme simplement
que dans notre pays l'Artisanat a
toujours considéré l'apprentissage comme
une filière de formation prioritaire et
que c'est pas pour nous un mode de
formation juste comme ça parce que c'est
la mode mais que c'est structurellement
parlant le mode de formation à l'accès
de nos métiers à à la création de nos
entreprises et à la reprise de celle-ci
et que donc naturellement nous apportons
nous attachons une importance tout à
fait considérable à
l'apprentissage qui est vraiment pour
nous fondamental et le premier constat
que permett de faire c'est que
globalement dans notre pays il y a une
évolution qu'il faut noter c'est que ça
n'est plus
aujourd'hui un débat entre droite et
gauche pour savoir si c'est utile ou pas
globalement que ça soit le président
Sarkozi le président Hollande on voit
bien que la priorité de l'apprentissage
fait partie aujourd'hui d'un constat
partagé ce qui est par rapport à ce
qu'on a vécu il y a 10 15 ou 20 ans
quelque chose pour nous d'extrêmement
positif deuxième chose est dans son
exposé monsieur Martino a redit la
différence qu'il y avait sur le fond et
l'objectif de l'apprentissage entre la
France et l'Allemagne vous avez cité
l'Allemagne mais on voit bien que les
pays comme l'Autriche comme la Suisse
sont également des exemples dans lequels
le développement de l'apprentissage
correspond à un chômage des jeunes qui
est bien plus réduit et que donc ce que
nous disions depuis très longtemps sur
l'apprentissage aujourd'hui est
confirmeré et je veux dire au début de
mon intervention que je partage une très
grande partie de ce qu'a dit Monsieur
Ferti de ce qu'a dit Monsieur martinau
sur l'apprentissage alors le constat de
la baisse du nombre d'apprentis bon il
est réel depuis maintenant 2 ans les
causes de cette baisse bon elles sont
naturellement il y en a pas eu une seule
il y a naturellement
l'activité une entreprise artisanale qui
a moins d'activité a tendance à
embaucher moins d'apprentis mais il est
évident quand on regarde des chiffres de
prêt que l'annonce qui a été faite et
auudelà de l'annonce de la réalité de
l'arrêt ou de la baisse du soutien au
maîtrre d'apprentissage a été de ce
sujet-là un élément déclencheur très
fort et une rupture du nombre de
contrats d'apprentissage même si
effectivement depuis un N de mesure ont
essayé de compenser cette décision ce
qui n'est pas pas encore totalement fait
mais on voit bien que cette décision a
été en terme d'image surtout
catastrophique c'était de la part de
l'état de dire oh ça n'est plus
important on on a plus d'action donc il
y a la baisse d'activité ces décisions
qui ont été prises en juin juuillet 2013
et puis ça a été dit également la
concurrence avec les contrats d'avenir
les emplois jeunes qui font
qu'effectivement le contrat
d'apprentissage s'est trouvé dans une
situation
particulière donc ça c'est le constat je
pense qu' aujourd'hui tout le monde
partage l'idée qu'il faut qu'on puisse
repartir dans dans la bonne direction
alors nous nous
considérons que
aujourd'hui il est
possible de
trouver un
accord assez consensuel sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais que il faut qu'on
aille vraiment sur le fond et pas
seulement sur un sujet mais pour
plusieurs et puis qu'on se mette
d'accord
collectivement pour que si il y a des
nouvelles mesures qui sont prises on
s'engage est-ce qu'elles soit prises et
pour une durée suffisamment longue pour
pas qu'elle soit modifiée ensuite tous
les 6 mois tous les 3 mois la stabilité
d'un dispositif est pour nous
extrêmement important pour nos
entreprises les entreprises artisanales
le fait d'avoir des modifications
régulières incessante euh mais chef
d'entreprise dans une situation
d'incertitude qui naturellement pas
propice à l'embauche et donc on souhaite
qu'il y ait un débat national sur le
sujet que ça soit une priorité partagée
et que les décisions étant prises il y a
un engagement d'un d'un gouvernement sur
une législature sur une période assez
longue pour que les entreprises soit
dans une sécurité dans leur
environnement alors ceci dit euh un des
points qui a été voté avancé par
Monsieur ferci monsieur Martino c'est la
place de l'éducation nationale dans le
dispositif nous nous partageons le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il
faut aller même jusqu'à dire qu'il faut
sortir l'éducation nationale en
particulier dans la construction des
référentiels des diplômes d'éducation
nationale ce qui a été dit concernant le
le cap aujourd'hui est très clair les
champs du méti l'artisanat ont été amené
à construire des diplômes des titres
pardon pour avoir des titres qui
correspondent mieux aux besoins des
entreprises parce que c'est nous qui
mettons avec les branches
professionnelles en place les
référentiels nous avons la faculté de
les modifier plus facilement et ils
correspondent mieux au besoins de nos
entreprises alors que les diplômes de
l'éducation nationale sont conçus de
façon à ce qu'effectivement
l'enseignement général aujourd'hui a une
place trop importante et donc correspond
plus au besoins des entreprises et donc
là je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
trancher et que les les diplômes et les
titres doivent totalement correspondre à
ses besoins et je crains fort que si ça
reste sous l'autorité d'éducation
nationale nous n'y arrivions pas et que
donc il y a une décision extrêmement
importante à prendre dans ce sujet en
donnant une place importante non pas au
chentes de métier mais aux branches
professionnelles qui connaissent mieux
euh les besoins des entreprises nous
nous sommes opérateurs dans l'opération
deuxième chose euh nous pensons qu'il
faut euh se pencher sur la situation des
apprentis alors je vais pas prendre la
place du représentant des apprentis mais
depuis longtemps nous militons pour
qu'il y ait une égalité de traitement
entre l'étudiant et l'apprenti sur le
plan très pratique hein en terme
d'hébergement en terme de culture en
terme d'accès au transport prendre un
exemple he dans un département le
Conseil départemental est en charge des
transport scolaires bah un apprenti
parce qu'il est salarié même quand le
bus passe devant chez lui il peut pas
prendre le le bus de transport scolaire
bon on pense quand même que il pourrait
y avoir de ce sujet des éléments très
positifs en faveur des apprentis de de
façon à ce que ceci soit réellement en
situation de pas avoir ses contraintes
n'oublions pas quand même qu'àapprenti
il a trois lieux de vie hein il a son
domicile le centre de formation et
l'entreprise et que donc le transport
pour lui est un élément extrêmement
important et il faut qu'on on se
mobilise pour que les jeunes puissent
avoir la possibilité d'accéder au
transport à un moindre coût en tout cas
ce sont pris en charge donc
l'hébergement la restauration le sport
la culture on doit dans notre pays
mettre les apprentis à égalité de
traitement avec les étudiants c'est
aussi extrêmement
important il faut qu'on travaille
également sur le mîre d'apprentissage et
sa valorisation former un apprenti c'est
un
engagement du mettre d'apprentissage et
il est nécessaire que de trouver des
dispositif c'est pas toujours très lourd
ça coûte pas toujours très cher mais
valoriser d'apprentissage reconnaître
son investissement dans la formation des
jeunes nous paraît un élément également
qui serait extrêmement
favorable alors si vous permettez
Monsieur ferrati juste une petite nuance
entre l'enseignement supérieur et et les
jeunes les plus en difficulté parce
qu'on on constate aujourd'hui que dans
le réseau de de l'artisanat on a à peu
près 30 % des jeunes qu'on appelle
décrocheurs des bac plus 1 bac + 2 qui
rentre en formation en apprentissage
pour passer un niveau un diplôme de
niveau 5 et que ces jeunes naturellement
il faut qu'il y ait un parcours
différent pour eux parce qu'ils ont un
enseignement général qui n'est plus à
refaire mais euh on on les on les mène
jusqu'au niveau 4 au niveau 3 hein euh
et donc on peut considérer que le niveau
3 c'est l'enseignement supérieur mais ce
sont des jeunes aussi qui eux-mêmes
avaient besoin de passer par
l'apprentissage en repassant au niveau 5
pour arriver à ce niveau 3 et donc il
rentre en apprentissage chez nous à 21
22 ans parce que ils ont un parcours
académique déjà relativement long et
donc dans le réseau de des champs du MCH
l'artisanat aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on n
appppelle plus les CFA CFA hein on
appelle université Régionale des Métiers
parce que pour nous euh la la formation
d'apprentissage ne peut pas se
concentrer uniquement au niveau 5 il
faut naturellement de passer du niveau 5
au niveau 4 au niveau 3 de façon à ce
qu'on est des apprentis qui soient à la
fois compétents dans les métiers mais
qui soit capable demain de reprendre une
entreprise ou d'en créer une et donc
lorsqu'on est dans des titres de niveau
3 on est aussi sur des éléments de
gestion d'entreprise et des gestion de
ressources humaines qui sont extrêmement
important
alors peut-être dernier point pour pas
être trop long le le financement alors
nous avons par rapport à ce qu'a dit
Madame la vice-présidente à mes côtés
des des différences extrêmement
importantes sur la vision du financement
de
l'apprentissage nous nous considérons
très clairement que la taxe
d'apprentissage doit aller à
l'apprentissage voilà et que le le
financement des grandes écoles par la
taxe d'apprentissage n'est aujourd'hui
de notre point de vue pas normal voilà
je dis pas qu'il faut pas d'argent pour
les grandes écoles mais la taxe
d'apprentissage ne doit pas être affect
au financement d'établissement qui soi
pas des établissements d'apprentissage
et que nous la collecte entre guillemets
on veut on souit pas spécialement
collecté on s'en fout le principal c'est
que les centres de formation soient
financés que donc à réussir la réforme
de la collecte n'est pas satisfaisante
aujourd'hui elle ne permet pas elle ne
permet pas de de faire arriver l'argent
là où la formation se fait au bout du
compte nous simplement un chiffre nous
formons dans l'artisanat 30% des
apprentis et nous collectons et nous
percevons 4 % de taxe d'apprentissage
voilà ça c'est un chiffre qui est
incontestable qui est connu aujourd'hui
et donc nous nous disons simplement
qu'il doit avoir un pourcentage de forme
de de taxe d'apprentissage correspondant
au nombre d'apprentis formés voilà c'est
une r très simple c'est facile à
calculer et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu' auquel on devrait arriver et
donc l'interlocuteur aujourd'hui on
trouve que c'est très bien c'est le
conseil régional qui de par les nouveaux
textes a la compétence entière sur
l'apprentissage y compris sur
l'orientation qui un élément extrêmement
important et donc ce qui nous paraît
essentiel c'est que le conseiler
régional étant le financeur il y ait il
est il est des ressources de taxes
d'apprentissage au conseil régional ça
nous gêne pas du tout à la condition que
cette ressource soit fléchée et
obligatoirement reverser à
l'apprentissage il il est arrivé
quelquefois que le certains conseillers
régionaux a pu
mélanger la recette et la dépense sans
toujours l'affecter au bon endroit et
donc c'est c'est bien qu'il y ait une
affectation obligatoire et donc voilà
nous nous souhaitons qu'il y ait par
rapport à ça plus de visibilité une
traçabilité deapprentissage une
affectation au au centres qui
utiliseent qui qui forme des apprentis
et donc en réalité notre souhait c'est
bien que on arrive à à travailler sur
l'ensemble des aspects de l'APEN sage le
MRE d'apprentissage le jeûe le
financement les titres les diplômes de
façon à ce que cette priorité soit une
priorité nationale collective partagée
sur une une durée qui soit stabilisée en
terme de
dispositif nos
entreprises sont culturellement prêtes à
pouvoir continuer et amplifier le nombre
d'apprentis je voudrais si vous
permettez terminer en en disant qu'on
est quand même dans euh un pays dans
lequel il y a un nombre de choses euh
qui fonctionneent pas moi je suis euh de
la région nordpcaléis nous avons
malheureusement 120000 jeunes
aujourd'hui qui sont euh dans l'émission
locale enfin qui sont en dehors de
parcours de l'emploi et dans euh
l'Université des métiers que je préside
nous avons 5200 apprentis mais nous
avons 1000 places de libre dans le
centre de formation donc quand vous avez
1000 places de libre et 120000 jeunes
qui aujourd'hui non pas de formation pas
d'emploid je pense que il y a un certain
nombre de questions qu'il faut se poser
parce qu'au bout du compte ça été
confirmé partout quand les jeunes
sortent de nos centres c'est 70 75 % qui
sont à l'emploi et donc est un peu
dommage qu'on narrive pas aujourd'hui à
mettre en adéquation les besoins des
entreprises qui restent réels les jeunes
qui sont au chômage et les outils de
formation qui sont aujourd'hui développé
dernier point moi je partage ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Martino euh c'est une erreur je
crois qui a été faite de la part du
gouvernement que d'arrêter le Fond
national de développement de
l'apprentissage qui était un bon outil
pour mettre en place ses contrats
d'objectifs moyens entre l'État et les
régions et ça permettait l'état même si
l'état s'occupe pas du fonctionnement
mais d'indiquer sa volonté politique de
développer l'apprentissage et les com
depuis quelques années ont permis
d'améliorer beaucoup les outils de
formation en investissement et je pense
que que ce ce Fond national qui était
alimenté par la taxe d'apprentissage il
aurait été bien qu'il puisse continuer
pour marquer la volonté gouvernementale
de développer ce mode de formation qui
aujourd'hui a reconnu pour son
efficacité merci de votre
attention et bien merci à vous et merci
en tout cas à tous les quatre des
éléments que vous nous avez apportés en
terme à la fois de constat d'éclairirage
mais également vous avez donné des
pistes et même des des éléments assez
concrets pr pour essayer de faire
reculer ce ce phénomène de la baisse de
l'apprentissage dans notre pays alors
nous avons maintenant quelques instants
pour pouvoir dialoguer avec la salle
j'aurais voulu peut-être donner la
parole à à à Catherine Moran sali qui
est présidente de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation et qui a donc
cette compétence en matière
d'apprentissage et puis je crois que des
travaux aussi sont faits ou en cours
dans cette commission donc je vous
laisse la parole bien volontiers merci M
madame la la présidente d'abord
permettez-moi de vous féliciter pour
l'organisation de cette table ronde qui
est extrêmement enrichissante pour
l'ensemble des collègues qui viennent
d'un ensemble de commissions certes la
commission de la culture l'éducation de
la communication a compétenence puisque
elle traite des questions relatives à à
l'éducation nationale et l'enseignement
supérieur mais également la Commission
des des affaires sociales et je crois
que la commission du développement
économique est forcément éminemment
intéressée euh par ce sujet donc encore
une fois merci d'avoir organiser cette
table ronde qui nous enrichit en plus
utilement dans une période où beaucoup
de collègues aussi euh se
prépare les l'arrivée des grandes
régions avec ses compétences renforcées
je crois que c'est le moment ou jamais
pour
enclencher des méthodes vertueuses des
décisions utiles à la promotion de de de
l'apprentissage alors au cœur de notre
commission forcément intéresse de longue
date à la question de de de
l'apprentissage et notamment l'effet
positifs en matière d'insertion
professionnelle pour les jeunes
particulièrement les jees les moins
qualifiés ce n'est plus à à démontrer au
cours de l'année 2013 nous nous sommes
émus de la baisse du nombre des
apprentis je rappis que les chiffres
c'est - 3,1 % en 2013 et cette baisse
concerne bien sûr les niveaux de
qualification les les les plus faibles
je note avec satisfaction comme vous que
le gouvernement s'est enfin mobilisé il
y a un an euh pour porter un objectif
ambitieux en matière de développement de
de l'apprentissage au sein de de
l'éducation nationale je rappellerai le
chiffres il s'agit d'augmenter d'ici
2017 de 50 % le nombre d'apprentis dans
les lycées publics pour atteindre
60000 apprentis vous dire qu'il y a eu
une décennie d'effort en faveur de
l'apprentissage dans dans l'éducation
nationale notamment euh relancé par la
loi d' Fillon la loi de de janvier de
2005 souvenez-vous des des débats sur le
le le collège unique sur le socle commun
de compétence et cette question de
l'apprentissage malgré tout
euh les efforts n'ont pas été suivis et
la place de cette filière de formation
demeure encore trop
marginale on peut noter que le nombre
d'apprentis a doublé depuis 2002 mais
que les 40000 apprentis de l'éducation
nationale c'est seulement au 10 % de
l'effectif global des des des apprentis
euh comme l'ont souligné à la fois les
les de nombreux travaux mais aussi les
interventions faites ce matin j'aiété
extrêmement attentive à ce qui a été dit
euh il y a des entrave persistante au
développement de de l'apprentissage au
sein de l'éducation nationale même alors
certaines sont d'ordre structurel
d'autres sont d'ordre culturel au rang
des des entraves d'ordre structurel vous
avez tout simplement le fait que l'accès
au formation en alternance est
insuffisamment pris en compte au sein
des procédures d'affectation et et ad
missission postb en en fin de de lycée
le fait que l'accueil d'apprentis au
sein des établissements scolaires se
HETE mes chers collègues à des règles de
gestion dissuasives et et
contreproductives par exemple savez-vous
que le nombre d'apprentis n'est pas pris
en compte lors de l'attribution des
dotations au aux établissements
scolaires troisièmement au nom d'une
orientation enfin du refus d'une
orientation trop précoce la loi de
refondation de l'école don nous débattu
en en 2013 a supprimé vous le savez les
filières de
préapprentissage euh et restreint le
dispositif d'initiation au métiers en
alternance dit
Dima ici nous avions bataillé pour
maintenir ce dispositif parce qu'on
considérait que c'était justement un
marche-pied vers la filière de de de
l'apprentissage qui offre des parcours
de récite de réussite alternatif au aux
jeunes qui ont besoin de trouver leur
voie à partir du du collège euh enfin je
soulignerai que la réforme du
baccalauréat professionnel elle est
désormais préparée en 3 ans et elle a
pénalisé
l'apprentissage du fait notamment de la
frilosité des entreprises à s'engager
pour 3 ans tout simplement dans un
contexte
économique difficile les obstacles
d'ordre
culturel encore une
fois les intervenants on ont évoqué
certains au sein de l'éducation
nationale c'est une F très très mal
connu pas du tout valorisé par les
enseignants pas plus par les conseillers
d'orientation qui toute façon sont sont
rares un vrai problème sur le
l'orientation cette orientation vers
l'apprentissage se fait toujours par
défaut et non pas par valorisation vers
de nobles métiers euh il y a des
rétisances affichées de la part des
enseignants de la filière professionnel
même et de leur syndicat qui voi dans
l'apprentissage une forme de concurrence
au lycée professionnel
classique C égard l'éducation nationale
peine à considérer les entreprises comme
des partenaires àarentiè en matière de
formation professionnelle ça a été
rappelé dans le cadre de la réflexion
sur les les diplômes qu'a fait monsieur
qui est tout à fait
exact euh ayant dit tout cela et pour
refaire bref il y a je pense des pistes
d'amélioration qui qui existe en
particulier par exemple le développement
des parcours mixtes de formation qui
vont mêler formations scolaire et et
alternance encore une fois cette mixité
des parcours heurte à des à des
résistances multiples alors c'est vrai
au sein de l'institution mais c'est vrai
au niveau des conseils régionaux ça a
été bien évoqué et l'élaboration des des
futurs PRDF doit être l'occasion de
réfléchir vraiment à tout cela ainsi que
la question de l'égalité entre les
étudiants et les et les apprentis on n'
pas parlé d'Erasmus mais je pense que
beaucoup militent pour un Erasmus des
des apprentis mais ce serait aussi une
façon de les passer sur pied l'égalité
des des enseignants
euh dernier point euh on peut gager
aussi que le développement de
l'apprentissage dans le prérecrutement
des enseignants dans le cadre notamment
du nouveau dispositif qui remplacera les
emplois d'avenir professeur sera enfin
l'amorce d'une évolution du regard porté
sur les les formations d'alternance au
sein des de
l'institution
euh pour conclure C un défi forcément de
taille seul une volonté politique forte
au niveau national mais régional peut
lever les les blocages dans le cadre
d'une démarche forcément partenariale ce
qui associe absolument l'état l'école
les entreprises les chambres de métiers
c'est
essentiel à la commission de la culture
on réfléchit beaucoup à ces questions
pour apporter notre pierre à l'édifice
justement dans ce moment un peu
stratégique on a engagé des travaux au
euh qu'on partagera bien sûr avec vous
il y a quelques semaines de cela et je
parle sous contrôle du rapporteur qui a
été désigné pour cette mission qui est
gu Dominique Kenel ici présent sur
l'orientation parce que l'orientation
c'est finalement la clé de voûe du
collège et malheureusement la réforme du
collège euh trop peu débattu dans la
fameuse loi de refondation de l'école
2013 n'a absolument pas pris en compte
la question de l'orientation qui est
finalement euh très pénalisante tant
qu'elle n'est pas résolue pour orienter
utilement et positivement les jeunes
vers vers l'apprentissage donc voilà
pourquoi nous avons engagé ces travaux
euh je crois que ça va dans le sens de
ce que fait la délégation aux
entreprises et les les autres
commissions du du
Sénat bien merci madame la Présidente
alors avant de de laisser la parole aux
uns et aux autres j'ai bien noté vos
demande d'intervention euh je vais
peut-être demander à Michel foressier
puis ensuite à agent euh à GUID
Dominique Kenel d'intervenir puisqueils
sont justement sur les travaux que vous
avez cité des travaux très récents
surtout le rapport qui a été je crois
présenté hier euh en commission euh
sociale cette fois alors Michel
foruissier
oui alors merci madame la Présidente
alors je je me suis investi avec
quelques collègues suite à un travail
que j'ai fait à mon arrivée au Sénat qui
était un rapport pour avis sur la
mission emploi et compte rattaché où
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer Bertand
martinau et et et d'échanger avec lui
dans le cadre d'audition euh sur la
problématique de l'apprentissage des
contrats aidés et puis aujourd'hui je
vois j'ai entendu avec intérêt aussi
Marc ferassi qui je pense nous ont à
tous les deux donné l'ensemble euh des
données essentielles sur le sujet alors
je voudrais être aussi très court
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne
pourra pas rentrer dans le détail des
sujets et pour moi pour vous dire que je
ne pense pas que ça soit un problème de
fonds supplémentairire à attribuer parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans un cadre budgétaire
contraint il faut se débrouiller avec
l'argent qu'on peut mobiliser et on peut
là les 3 x 3 que nous a expliqué Bertand
martinau démontre qu'en mant trois fois
plus d'argent on a trois fois moins de
réussite donc ça veut dire que quelque
part c'est pas que l'argent qui compte
bien sûr j'iraai pas non plus dans la
caricature et vous dire que sans argent
on peut tout faire c'est pas ça mon
propos mais simplement qu'aujourd'hui
moi je voudrais attirer l'attention de
mes collègues sur le fait qu'on consacre
beaucoup d'argent à des contrats aidés
et que à la sortie de ces contrats aidés
il y a peu de mise à l'emploi alors que
l'apprentissage conduit beaucoup plus à
à
l'emploi j'ai le prisme particulier de
quelqu'un qui a géré une entreprise
artisanale depuis 1968 en mai 68 j'ai
créé ma première entreprise dans le les
métiers de la pierre la sculpture et
tout ce qui tout ce qui va avec
restauration d'ouvrage historique et
j'ai toujours formé tout le personnel en
formation interne pas forcément même en
allant jusqu'à des contrats
d'apprentissage mais parce qu' aussi
dans C un métier on a cette
particularité où on a une culture
professionnelle et où on forme aussi des
gens responsables et des citoyens ça il
faut pas l'oublier je pense
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement les
missions
locales tout ce qui est des structures
locales pour
l'emploi ont pié à des déficiences des
structures nationales mais aujourd'hui
on part un peu dans tous les sens et en
partant dans tous les sens on perd en
efficacité c'est pour ça que le premier
point que je crois qui a été mis en
évidence et qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'au moment où on va appliquer la loi
nôre il faut s'inspirer de l'Allemagne
et de se dire c'est pas parce qu'on a
transféré des compétences que l'État
doit rester absent des pilotage et ça
c'est la la grosse difficulté parce que
en France on a toujours tendance à
passer à l'autre ce qui est compliqué
sans forcément lui en donner les moyens
et en lui disant ben maintenant que la
compétence il débrouille non je crois
qu'il y a notment des des filières
professionnelles on avait pris l'exemple
par exemple de la maintenance des
éoliennes il va pas y avoir une
formation dans chaque région il y a de
la place pour une formation en France
donc je crois qu'il y a une échelle
aussi des formations qui est
importante je pense aussi que il y a la
il faut il faut fédérer autour des du
nouveau projet qu'on a à bâtir les
partenaires
comme en Allemagne c'estàd que la la le
principe de se dire l'état prélève et
redistribue pose un problème parce
qu'effectivement on se rend compte on
appelle une taxe d'apprentissage et on
se rend compte qu'il y a peu d'argent de
la collèue de la taque qui arrive sur
l'apprentissage donc il vaudrait mieux
être dans un système comme en Allemagne
où on considère que pour le chef
d'entreprise c'est le développement d'un
facteur humain la la compét et c'est un
enruchissement pour l'entreprise qui a
un vivier de personnel formé à un métier
en plus la relation avec l'Éducation
nationale en France ça a toujours été
compliqué de mettre un politique de
mettre un chef d'entreprise et
l'éducation nationale parce que chacun
voulant bien entendu mordre un petit peu
sur les compétences ou sur les missions
de l'autre je n'irai pas jusqu'à
caricaturer ce qu'on entend très souvent
que toute la faute repose à l'éducation
nationale parce que je pense qu'on a un
système éducatif quoi qu'on en dise où
on a beaucoup de gens qui s'investissent
et qu'il faut soutenir mais là aussi il
faut être sur un pilotage qui soit
équilibré et sur un investissement
réciproque qui permette de fédérer
autour du projet parce que voyez
l'Allemagne État fédéral arrive à avoir
un pilotage national alors qu'en France
notre principe républicain qui d'une
manière constitutionnelle que tous les
citoyens doivent être traités de la même
façon sur le territoire on se rend
compte qu'on y'y arrive pas donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
continue à s'investir sur ce sujet mais
on ne pourra pas arriver à des solutions
durables dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage si on ne rebtit pas un
code du travail en France approprié au
21e siècle parce que dans
l'apprentissage c'est quand même le
monde du travail évidemment avec
l'Éducation nationale qui doit valider
les diplômes qui doit s'assurer de la
qualité de l'enseignement mais pour
moi c'est c'est un tout et aujourd'hui
on a une chance inouie c'est que dans
l'application de la loi nôtre les
régions ont le pouvoir
d'expérimentation et moi je crois
beaucoup à à certaines régions
j'appartiens à la région ronalpe qui est
quand même une très grosse région il y a
beaucoup de d'économie et ma collègue
l'a dit avant moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est dans nos projets
régionaux qu'il faut réfléchir quelle va
être la place de la région et surtout
les liens avec les autres institution
parce qu'aujourd'hui moi je ne connais
pas de système euh qui puisse
fonctionner correctement si on n' pas un
organigramme clair et sur
l'apprentissage c'est un cas typique euh
à un moment donné on se dit mais ça
dépend de qui et puis aussi il faut
aussi pardonnez-moi c'est une une vue
politique mais enfin je fais aussi la
politique on va dire même à temps
complet ce qu'il y a d'important ça
serait qu'on puisse fédérer comme ça se
fait en Allemagne les syndicats de
salariés d'un côté et les syndicats
patronaux de l'autre parce que s'il
parlait d'une seule voix pardonnez-moi
mesdames et messieurs ça serait quand
même plus facile pour nous de pouvoir de
pouvoir ti parce que aujourd'huiil faut
déjà qu'on met tout le monde d'accord
avant de avir sur chaque sujet ça ne
marche pas donc je crois qu' il y a cet
Arbor essence qu'il faut trouver
excusez-moi d'avoir été trop
long merci alors donc
ensuite Guy Dominique Kenel aussi qui
peut nous faire part de ses travaux et
après j'ai noté un certain nombre de
demandes nous allons essayer d'aller
dans les temps qui nous sont impartis
alors je vais essayer d'être le plus
bref et quand je dis ça c'est c'est
c'est dangereux parce que habituellement
on est très longent
euh d'abord vous dire que bon j'ai une
petite expérience en matière
d'apprentissage puisque j'ai été
directeur de centre de formation
d'apprentis pendant 10 ans et ensuite
après inspecteur de l'Éducation
nationale en charge de l'apprentissage
parce qu'aucun de mes autres collègues
n'a souhaité le faire euh ça vous dit
tout alors sans remonter à ma Matusalem
simplement vous dire que l'apprentissage
souffre de son image et pourquoi parce
que que il fut un temps avant que ce ne
soit ouvert aux autres niveaux que le
niveau 5 l'orientation vers
l'apprentissage se faisait par la
négative et là j'en viens tout de suite
au système d'orientation en disant tu
n'es pas fait pour des études donc
automatiquement tu vas vers un métier et
je pense que l'erreur qui a été commise
au départ bien que il y ait eu des
propositions dans ce domaine-là c'est de
maintenir le terme apprentissage dès
lors que l'ouverture s'est faite vers
les niveaux 4 3 2 1 et cetera je pense
qu'on aurit aurait dû trouver un autre
sigle lié plus au métier qu'à
l'apprentissage et je pense que dans
l'esprit de l'ensemble des personnes a
commencé par les parents d'ailleurs
parce que parce que au niveau de
l'orientation évidemment quand on
propose aux parents que que le jeune
doit aller vers un métier de la bouche
plutôt que de faire un enseignement
général et un bacaisse évidemment vous
connaissez la la réaction et la
proposition des parents et je pense que
d le départ il y a eu un problème
d'image qu'on n pas corrigé à ce
moment-là deuxième élément que que que
je voulais indiquer c'est que en
complément de ce qu'a dit Monsieur
martinau dans le code du travail il est
clairement précisé aussi que l'apprenti
a un contrat de travail de type
particulier qui intègre une durée de
formation or en France on n' jamais pris
en compte que la primauté c'était le
contrat de travail c'est-à-dire priorité
à l'entreprise et ce qui s'y fait et
c'est ce qu'on retrouve vous vous vous
aurez compris à mon accent que
géographiquement je suis proche de
l'Allemagne et de la Suisse et que
évidemment nous connaissons bien le
système d'en face le système dual qui
est orienté différemment et que la
primuté est donnée bien sûr à à
l'apprentissage du métier et ensuite à
l'insertion à l'évolution
professionnelle je crois que là aussi il
y a un switch à faire qui qui n'est pas
évident alors se pose le problème
d'entrée d'entrée c'est-à-dire
l'orientation l'orientation quand bon on
peut dire les régions doivent s'en
occuper et cetera c'est vrai mais au
départ au départ l'orientation se fait
où elle se fait en 3e et elle se fait
par les professeurs principaux des
collèges et et très souvent tout
simplement les professeurs ignorent
l'entreprise non pas parce que ma fois
il ils n'ont pas besoin de l'entreprise
mais parce qu'ils ne la connaissent pas
et je crois que c'est ce défaut qui
existe d'entrée de jeu au niveau de
l'orientation les parents qui préfèrent
voir une belle carrière intellectuelle à
leurs enfants qu' ce qu'on ne peut pas
contester et et et deuxièmement les les
professeurs principaux en charge de
l'orientation voir les conseillers
d'orientation psychologue qui ignor la
plupart du temps d'ailleurs le
fonctionnement d'une entreprise donc
parce que elle n'est pas intégrée dans
leur formation initiale et je crois que
là il y a effectivement un
gourien qui qui doit être levé et et et
qui ne permet pas justement de donner
ces lettres de noblesse à à à
l'apprentissage dernier élément c'est
vrai que l'éducation nationale a
toujours souhaité conserver
l'apprentissage sous sa coupe non pas
pour en faire la promotion mais tout
simplement pour avoir j'allais dire
quelques
débouchés subaltern pour un certain
nombre de de de leurs enfants
pardonnez-moi je suis assez je suis
assez cruel assez violent bien que ça a
été l'éducation nationale ma maison
depuis depuis le départ mais mais
simplement pour dire l'éducation
nationale résomme par rapport à ses
propres besoins qui sont le diplôme et
non pas la formation professionnelle et
l'insertion et je crois que là aussi
Philippe séin déjà à l'époque souhaitit
que l'apprentissage relève du ministère
du Travail il y a toujours eu un blocage
à ce niveau-là et je pense l'avoir
entendu tout à l'heure que évidemment
l'apprentissage devrait relever d'un
autre ministère que le ministère
l'éducation nationale alors je vous dis
pas celui qui réussira à le faire euh
euh je je je voilà on pourra le
féliciter collectivement mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai dans la définition des
diplômes faut pas s'étonner que le
baccalauréat professionnel euh ne soit
pas finalement la panassée au niveau de
l'apprentissage c'est évident le bac pro
n'a pas été fait pour l'enseignement
professionnel elle n'a pas été fait pour
les entreprises le Bac Pro a été fait
tout simplement pour caser un certain
nombre d'él qui ne pouvait ni aller dans
le bac général ni dans le bac
technologique il faut être faut être
franc dans ce qu'on dit et moi c'est la
pratique qui me fait parler donc
automatiquement je crois que il y a dans
le processus d'orientation et dans le
rapport que nous soumettrons d'ici le
mois de février prochain à à l'ensemble
de nos collègues un certain nombre
d'orientations nouvelles à donner et
tout simplement d'impact nouveau à
apporter pour redonner aussi ces lettres
de Nobless à l'apprentissage je ne me
fais pas trop d'illusion au départ parce
que quand je dis contrat de travail de
type particulier ça veut dire aussi et
là je m'adresse au au président de la
PCMA et puis également à la Chambre de
commerce il faudra que la prise en
compte au niveau de l'entreprise soit
très forte aussi ce qui est le cas en
Allemagne il y a même des des des des
salariés qui sont détachés pour encadrer
et et former les apprentis parce qu'au
départ c'est un investissement au niveau
de de l'entreprise et et l'apprenti
n'est pas entre guillemets rentable au
sein de l'entreprise notamment la
première année surtout si la prise en
charge n'est pas faite correctement si
elle est faite correctement il devient
rentable dès la 2e année j'en ai fait la
preuve au niveau de la pédagogie de
l'alternance donc simplement pour vous
dire que à ce niveau-là aussi il faut
qu'il y ait quelques lettres de noblesse
qui soit donné au sein de l'entreprise
d'abord à l'apprenti mais aussi à celui
qui l'encadre et je pense que dans ce
cas de figure on pourra peut-être
avancer et je crois pas que ce soit une
question de moyen et là je rejoins mon
collègue je pense pas que ce soit une
question de moyen c'est une question
d'origine au départ question de de de
justement d'image à redonner à
l'apprentissage et en même temps dire
aussi aux parents et dire aux jeunes que
lorsque vous avez un métier vous avez de
l'or entre vos mains et que finalement
vous réussissez peut-être mieux que ceux
qui ont un baccalauréat voir des packs +
4 + 5 et qui sont au chômage aujourd'hui
et là aussi bon psychologiquement il y a
du boulot merci bien merci pour ces
témoignage donc en fonction des demandes
de prise de parole on va essayer de de
grouper et de faire un peu court et puis
les intervenants répondront donc une
première série Dominique Estrosi Sasson
Serge dassassau et Nicole brick à
Dominique qui commence je vais être très
rapide parce que aucun d'entre vous n'en
a parlé c'est un sujet qui a toujours
fait l'objet de discussions de débats y
compris entre nos différents grand
formation politique qu'en est-il pour
vous de la baisse de l'âge de
l'apprentissage on en a souvent parlé on
en a souvent fait un objet ou en tout
cas potentiellement inclure dans des
programmes politiques où on a souvent
dit il faudrait baisser l'âge de
l'apprentissage à 14 ans et comme on n
pas vous n'avez pas fait référence je
vous souhaite simplement avoir vos avis
très bien merci Serge
Daau
remerci président d'AB remercier Mad
présidente d'avoir organisé cette table
ronde tout à fait
passionnante monsieur làbas qui vient de
parler je sais pas comment il s'appelle
Kenel il a raison il y a diplôme et
métier
l'éducation ne sert qu'à faire des
diplômes qui ne servent souvent à rien
moi j'ai des petits ENF qui
sont université je leur dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire plus
tard ah on sait pas bon ils apprenent
des tas de truc mais il savent pas ce
qu'ils font après c'est quand on a un
métier on a un métier on sait de quoi
faire et je vis vous poser une question
à à vous tous est-ce que vous savez quel
est le principal obstacle de
l'apprentissage en
France pourquoi ça ne marche pas
pourquoi on y arrive
pas savez pas vous allez ri dire vous
l'avez pas prononcé ce mot c'est le
collège
unique le collège unique est une
catastrophe pour l'apprentissage des
enfants soi-disant veut que tout le
monde a les mêmes connaissances ce n'est
pas possible moi j'étais maire d'une
commune
Corbon il y avait tous les ans et il y a
toujours d'ailleurs 4 à 500 jeunes qui
sortent du collège sans savoir rien
faire et sans aller où
ils vont pas dans l'essé ils vont nulle
part et qu'est-ce qu'il deviennent
malheureusement souvent des délinquants
ils traînent ils font des bêtises et
cetera s'ils avaient un métier ils
travailleraient or on le apprend pas un
métier et il faudrait que la la sortie
de
primaire ce qui est le cas dans d'autres
pays on fasse une sélection entre les
gosses qui sont capables d' faire des
diplômes et ceux qui veulent apprendre
un métier il faut leur apprendre un
métier à partir de 14 ans et pas à la
sortie du collège ou avant c'est trop
tard il faut qu'il commence donc le
problème est un problème aussi d'image
vous l'avez dit l'apprentissage en
mauvaise image mais finalement pour tous
les enfants il faut le apprendre un
métier et il y a les missions locales
dont on a parlé aussi qui essayent après
l'éducation qui s'en fout l'aducationale
ne ne s'en occupe pas il finance pas les
CFA il financec pas les missions locales
qui bricolle après pouressortir les
jeunes de leur situation donc tout ça ça
vient du collège unique il faut que vous
tous vous demandiez la suppression du
colège unque avec la formation
professionnelle dès la sortie de la
primaire et puis la formation diplôme
pour ceux qui veulent faire des diplômes
mais qui souvent d'ailleurs serv rien il
y a 150000 jeunes par an depuis 15 ans
15 ans tout le monde s'en fout les les
les mises éducation sociale s'en fout
qu'est-ce qu'il font ce bofgaz et ils
sort du collège du lycée ou de
l'université sans savoir rien faire et
c'est pour ça qu'il a le chôage des
jeunes en France qui a part en Allemagne
parce que il on pas bien mer problème
ser rendre un métier et pas des diplômes
je vais donc passer la parole à Nicole
brick maintenant oui merci madame la
Présidente moi j'ai deux questions
concrètes contenu de l'heure et que il
va nous falloir aller en séance euh la
première s'adresse au président gris
dans son propos il a au sein de même
corp de phrase vous avez mis côte à côte
peut-être avec une virgule je ne sais
pas euh la
baisse de
l'apprentissage qui a été chiffré tout à
l'heure et les la montée des contrats
aidés et notamment des contrats d'avenir
alors je voudrais que vous étayez un peu
votre propos sur des chiffres sur un
commentaire ça me paraît important et
puis la deuxième question elle est à
celui qui qui voudra y répondre mais de
l'intérêt des statistique sexué parce
que je lis dans la note j'ai lu dans la
note euh fort bien achalandé de la
délégation aux entreprises dont je fais
partie que les femmes ne les jeunes
femmes ne représentaient que
1/ers des contrats d'apprentissage et ma
question c'est pourquoi je je la pose
parce que on le sait les économistes le
savent la croissance potentielle euh
elle repose beaucoup la l'amélioration
elle repose beaucoup sur les femmes dans
la vie active ça un effet
macro-économique vous le savez et donc
est-ce que c'est parce qu'elles sont
moins nombreuses dans ces filières au
départ alors là il y a un effet
mécanique ou est-ce que euh les
formations ne sont pas adaptées
à à
elle parce que je pense que c'est quand
même très important et j'ai toujours
plaidé pour garder des statistiques
sexuelles voilà un bon exemple merci
madame la Présidente et à vos services
merci donc déjà si vous pouviez répondre
à la fois sur sur alors il y a des
questions très précises au président
Griset sur l'âge de l'apprentissage le
collège unique qui est-ce qui prend la
parole monsieur
ferrati peut-être sur à la fois sur
l'âge de l'apprentissage et les
statistiques sexu sur les statistiques
je pense qu'il y a un effet il y a un
effet
sectoriel qui est que contrairement à
l'Allemagne l'apprentissage pèse en
France ENF plutôt surtout localisé
surtout localisé dans des filières qui
sont pas forcément les filières services
et tertières et que il y a dans
l'inconscient collectif l'idée que
peut-être aussi dans l'esprit des
familles l'idée que les garçons vont
plutôt vers l'industrie les filles
plutôt vers le tertiire même si c'est
pas forcément une loi je pense qu'il y a
un effet sectoriel je pense que ce cette
proportion d' tière qui est très faible
qu'il faudrait accroître tient aussi au
fait que on devrait plus développer
l'apprentissage dans le secteur des
services sur sur l'age de
l'apprentissage c'est une question c'est
une question
lourde je pense que pour y répondre il
faut s'intéresser à ce que deviennent
les apprentis sur la longue période et
j'ai pas beaucoup insisté là-dessus par
manque de temps mais ce que nous disent
les évaluations économiques qui
regardent toute la trajectoire
professionnelle des apprentis en la
comparant avec celle de de gens qui ne
sont pas passés par l'AP apprentissage
c'est que l'apprentissage a un très fort
effet positif à court terme sur
l'ination professionnelle mais et c'est
un ma il faut y faire attention que
l'apprentissage peut aussi freiner ou
empêcher des reconversions
professionnelles sur le tard pourquoi
parce que l'apprentissage procure des
compétences assez spécifiques à un
métier et que si on fait l'impasse sur
ce qu'on appelle le capital humain
général les compétences de base les
compétences fondamentales et bien dans
un monde qui implique à un moment ou un
autre des reconversions professionnelles
on prend le risque on prend le risque de
ne pas permettre de ne pas outiller les
gens pour ce type de reconversion en
commençant l'apprentissage trop tôt
c'est-à-dire en limitant les savoirs
fondamentaux donc je pense qu'il faut
prendre garde à ça et ça appelle une
seconde remarque concernant
l'institution ou plutôt le cadre
institutionnel de notre système
d'alternance au sens large c'est qu'on a
deux contrats on a le contrat de
professionnalisation qui s'adresse
potentiellement plus de 26 ans mais qui
en réalité concerne beaucoup de gens qui
ont moins de 26 ans et qui pourrai aller
en apprentissage on a le contrat
apprentissage la professionnalisation a
moins d'exigence en terme de formation
puisque avec 150 heures de formation on
peut ouvrir on peut on peut accéder à un
contrat de professionnalisation et
l'apprentissage comme on l'a dit donne
accès à un diplôme avec peut-être des
exigences en termees de formation qui
sont trop élevé par rapport au besoins
des entreprises et Bertrand martinau a
rappelé tout à l'heure qu'on en
Allemagne on passait moins de temps sur
les sur les bandes des CFA lorsqu'on est
en contrat d'apprentissage donc il y a
un enjeu qui consiste peut-être à
rapprocher les deux modèles faire en
sorte que l'apprentissage soit un peu
plus proche des besoins des entreprises
mais aussi faire faire en sorte que la
professionnalisation et des exigences en
terme de formation qui permettent
justement justement et bien d'envisager
des reconversions professionnelles
futures donc il y a il y a un enjeu
aussi de simplification du système à cet
égard euh président
Gret oui euh madame la ministre sur le
le le fait que les jeunes filles IR un
apprentissage il y a des constats
aujourd'hui mais il y a eu beaucoup de
progrès néanmoins il y en a beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui que précédemment bon
c'est vrai que dans le secteur de
l'artisana il y a quand même des métiers
où il est par exemple en esthétique il y
a pas beaucoup de garçons bon il y a des
métiers qui sont Mme plutôt fléchés en
fonction qu'on soit garçon ou fille mais
il y a des évolutions considérables et
on voit aujourd'hui dans bon nombre de
filières même dans le bâtiment hein dans
l'alimentation pas mal de jeunes filles
qui viennent mais on est quand même
encore dans une culture dans une vision
globale mais nous souhaitons
naturellement pouvoir
développer le nombre de jeunes filles
dans les formations et et souvent elles
y apporent beaucoup et on y est
favorable sur l'apprentissage à 14 ans
le dispositif qui qui a longtemps existé
de préapprentissage on était pas tout à
fait dans l'apprentissage clasi de
préapprentissage de à 14 ans a démontré
que pour un certain nombre de public en
grande difficulté c'était une solution
pour éviter de de traîner pendant des
années dans le système académique
classique et donc nous y sommes plutôt
favorables et là tous les démontre que
ça a été souvent une réussite concernant
les la concurrence avec les contrats
aidés madame les contrats d'avenir bon
je crois que Monsieur Martinou l'a dit
lui-même très bien toute la mobilisation
les objectifs donnés aux préfets qui ont
eux-mêmes fait retomber sur toutes les
structures de façon très dynamique le
fait qu'il fallait donner une priorité
au contrat d'avenir et aux emplois
jeunes on naturellement mobiliser la
totalité de l'énergie sur ces contrats
et ont laissé tomber la priorité sur la
rentissage tout ça est démontré dans
l'ensemble des départements de France
sans exception les préfets ont très bien
fait leur travail he ils avaient des
chiffres à à rendre quasiment tous les
mois et donc naturellement la pression
était telle que ces contrats ont été
prioritaires sur les contrats
d'apprentissage mais c'est un effet
conjoncturel pas structurel
naturellement mais parce que les
contrats ont d les préfets l'état
avaient donné objectif très clair et
donc pendant cette période là
effectivement on a vu que la priorité
n'était pas cont s sur l' des services
de l'État ça sur le sur la question de
la tutelle apprentissage éducation
nationale ou ministère de l'Économie
est-ce que quelqu'un ve en dire un
mot alors en tant ancien en tant qu'en
responsable au ministère de l'Emploi je
serai tendance à dire il faut tout
ramener au travail et à l'emploi euh en
fait ça ça serait compliqué
euh il y a il y a trois problèmes bon
d'abord il faut savoir que le ministère
du Travail il a pas les personnels pour
faire ça il y a pas ni ni au niveau
déconcentré où il y a plus personne ni
ni au niveau central sachez qu'à la
Délégation générale à l'emploi et la
formation professionnelle les personnes
qui s'occupent de l'apprentissage c'est
trois personnes voilà mais je je dis pas
enfin pour ce que le ministère du
Travail a à faire c'est c'est c'est tout
à fait suffisant mais enfin il faudrait
recruter des des dizaines et des
dizaines de personnes et CETA donc il y
a un problème de personnel de
qualification et cetera bon mais ça la
limite ça peut se régler on peut on sait
faire du Lego administratif voilà le le
deuxième sujet c'est c'est quand même
que dans un système d'apprentissage le
minimum d'un système d'apprentissage
c'est un référentiel de diplômes
nationaux c'est ce qui existe en
Allemagne et ça techniquement c'est
quand même l'éducation nationale qui
doit faire techniquement la maintenance
de ses diplômes alors là où il faut que
les entreprises participent beaucoup
plus c'est sur la partie professionnelle
mais sur la partie stron commun
enseignement général même si je
considère qu'il faudrait la réduire pour
le meilleur et pour le pire mais
l'éducation nationale est
incontournable trème élément l'éducation
nationale est tout tout à fait
incontournable sur un élément qui a été
beaucoup souligné qui est l'orientation
c'est pas le ministère du Travail qui va
orienter les gosses à 16 ans ou à 14 ans
ou à 15 ans donc donc essayer de couper
le lien avec le mistère de l'éducation
nationale je pense que ça peut pas se
faire je crois qu'il faut plutôt que
l'éducation nationale sa culture à
l'apprentissage je dis pas que c'est
simple mais je crois que c'est
incontournable plutôt que d'essayer de
lui extirper l'apprentissage et de le
redonner au ministère du Travail ou
pourquoi pas au ministère de l'Économie
et cetera pour des raisons vraiment
techniques je juste si vous avez
une minute 2 minutes d'abord je partage
tout ce qui a été dit sur les fonds les
fonds publics sur l'apprentissage on
peut dire qu'ils sont plutôt pas bien
réparti il y a tout un tas de problèmes
il faudrait pas reparler de la taxe
d'apprentissage une partie qui qui va au
région qui est pas reversée à
l'apprentissage tout ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Griset je suis en grande partie
d'accord il y a un problème de
répartition des moyens cela étant
globalement c'est peut-être la vraie
bonne nouvelle c'est globalement on a
pas de problème d'argent on a pas de
problème d'argent au passage au passage
le réservoir si on veut faire 100000
150000 apprentis en plus en France le
réservoir on sait où il est il est dans
les lycées professionnels ils sont il
son pas sur la planète pars les jeunes
bon donc ils sont dans les lycées
professionnels or la bonne nouvelle
c'est que une année de formation en
lycée professionnel ça coûte 12000 €
pour les finances publiques toujours
alors que l'apprentissage ça coûte 8500
9000 € ça dépend des années parce que ça
change chaque année les primes changent
on a une instabilité terrible mais enfin
ça coûte 8500 € à peu près par an et par
et par apprenti euh pour l'ensemble des
finances publiques je mets la région
l'État et cetera donc exonération de
charge et ceeta donc ça veut dire qu'à
chaque fois que vous allez transférer
enfin basculer un jeune d'un lycée pro
vers l'apprentissage vous allez faire
des économies sur les finances publiques
donc moi je prétends qu'on peut faire
100 150000 apprentis de plus en faisant
des économies sur les finances publiques
on a pas de problème d'argent en France
sur l'éducation et la formation en
général simplement l'argent est
terriblement mal réparti dernier point
sur le l'âge l'âge à 16 ans je rappelle
en Allemagne l'apprentissage c'est 16
ans et c'est 3 ça dure 3 ans pas 2 ans
et demi ou et cetera ça dure 3 ans les
entreprises s'engagent sur 3 ans et
d'ailleurs ça induit un modèle
économique différent puisque sur 3 ans
l'apprenti est rentable en Allemagne il
est rentable parce qu'il produit parce
qu'il est déjà préembauché parce qu'il
va coûter moins cher et cetera
l'apprentissage alors maintenant à avant
16 ans moi j'ai toujours été
relativement hostile pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord beaucoup beaucoup de
chefs d'entreprise disent qu'à 14 ans
les jeunes sont pas mature déjà à 16 ans
les jeunes savent pas ce qu'ils veulent
faire ils sont totalement immatures et
cetera ils savent pas du tout donc ce
qu'il faut faire c'est développer
absolument du préapprentissage des
stages des stages de découverte de
l'orientation et peut-être c'est ce que
je propose c'est à l'intérieur du
collège créer des filières un peu
spécifiques qui font des pr du
préapprentissage pas un contrat de
travail mais des stages de découverte
dans l'entreprise moi je connais des
jeunes qui ont fait un stage bête de une
semaine mais vraiment presque machine à
café vous voyez et il ils ont discuté
avec les gens d'entreprise et à la
sortie ils voulaient faire de
l'apprentissage hein donc il faut
vraiment penser euh cette question du
présapprentissage de la transition
peut-être travailler sur le collège
unique peut-être faire des évaluations
sur les compétences des élèves y compris
comportementales euh à la à la 5e en en
5e et euh faire des filières un peu
spécifiques à partir de la 4e pour
faciliter la transition vers
l'apprentissage mais la signature de
contrat d'apprentissage à 14 ans me
paraît euh à la fois pas vraiment
correspondre à la réalité de ce que sont
les jeunes aujourd'hui pu accessoirement
à ce qu'est l'économie moderne c'est
dire que quand même des métiers qui sont
faisables à 14 ans et qui ouvrent des
perspective il y en a quand même plus
beaucoup dans l'économie du 21e siècle
on est quand même globalement dans une
montée en gamme des compétences il faut
essayer de laisser le moins de monde
possible sur le bord du
chemin alors si vous voulez bien je suis
obligée de de de regarder l'heure mais
pour dire d'abord à nos collègues que en
fait la session ordinaire a été ouverte
cette nuit donc ça veut pas dire que
c'est pas important d'aller en séance
mais ça nous laisse ça nous laisse 5 ou
10 minutes de plus donc je vais prendre
les trois questions suivantes et on
essaiera de d'être les uns et les autres
très synthétiques c'est ce que je vous
demande donc nous avons Olivier cadiic
Martial Bourquin et anck billon voilà
alors Olivier
cadiic merci madame la Présidente oui
première question c'est ça a été évoqué
à un moment 2 tiers des deux apprentis
sur tris donc en Allemagne suivent donc
sont embauchés dans l'entreprise qui les
a reçu en France c'est un sur TR donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner une
idée de qui justifie le fait que il y a
un tel écart euh la deuxème question
enfin très
intéressante intervention de Monsieur
Martino par contre je suis un petit peu
gêné par la deuxième partie vous savez
en terme de d'entrepreneur de chef
d'entreprise moi quand je recrute
quelqu'un c'est pas le diplôme qui
m'intéresse c'est la compétence qu'il a
acquis parce que c'est ça qui va êre
être partie prenante pour faire
fonctionner mon entreprise et quand
j'avais dû recruter un apprenti j'ai
créé ma société à 20 ans dans
l'électronique à 24 ans j'ai voulu
recruter un apprenti pour qu'il fasse un
BTS électronique à 24 à 24 ans les
avions Marcel d'assaut me faisait
confiance pour dessiner les commandes de
vol du premier Rafal et bien 24 ans un
inspecteur d'académie ne me faisait pas
confiance pour prendre en apprentissage
un jeune en BTS électronique voilà
exactement à la même année euh et donc
ce qui est intéressant dans dans
l'approche de dire si on bascule
effectivement l'apprentissage de
l'éducation nationale vers vers le côté
emploi et les entreprises en leur
faisant confiance est-ce que vous avez
une une idée de l'économie sur le budget
deétion nationale puisque ça ferait
beaucoup de profs en moins donc quand
vous dites le coût est trois fois
supérieur est-ce que vous avez intégré
cette dimension du coût dans l'éducation
nationale de ses profs si on faisait
cette économie parce que ça je pense que
ça ça pourrait être intéressant d' point
de vue budgétaire 3è 3ème point c'est
effectivement ça a été évoqué par
Madame notre collègue Carine main de
sailli et ça a été aussi évoqué par par
vous et là par contre je suis tout à
fait en accord c'est la question des
stages d'immersion avant 16 ans parce
que il est évident que bah ça ça donne
pour le jeune vous avez je suis d'accord
aussi sur ce côté maturité c'est normal
on découvre et c'est vrai que en faisant
un stage d'une semaine ou deux semaines
ça peut éviter de d'aller vers un
apprentissage qui échouera parce que
finalement le jeune dira c'est pas c'est
pas mon truc enfin 4e point et je
profite de de l'avenue de de Françoise
Gattel parce que c'était une de ses
remarques hier lors sur la question de
de
l'apprentissage puisque Catherine Morin
de a aussi parlé d'érasmus de
l'apprentissage donc passer d'un pays à
l'autre et là se pose la problématique
des législations et des normes que nous
avons en France et Françoise l'a
justement résumé hier comment
voulez-vous être un apprenti couvreur si
vous vous n'êtes pas autorisé à monter
sur un toit et donc ça c'est aussi un
problème que nous avons et je pense que
ça aussi c'est comment est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on puisse l'adresser parce que
qui dit emploie d'immobilité
professionnelle merci ensuite Martial
Bourquin oui
concernant les comparaisons entre
l'Allemagne et et la France c'est très
utile simplement comparons ce qui est
comparable on a une industrie différente
déjà deuxième chose on a
en Allemagne l'alternance est le cœur du
système
éducatif c'est la seule voie pour aller
à certains métier
et l'apprentissage est un espace
légitime de qualification complètement
légitimé au niveau de la société en
France nous avons une dualité entre LCÉE
professionnel et l'apprentissage si bien
que nous trouvons avec quasiment deux
filières de formation et donc
réfléchissons un peu comment nous
pouvons mieux valoriser et quels que
soient les
alternance l'alternance l'alternance en
France et de ce point de vue je pense
que les régions doivent avoir la main
les régions doivent avoir la main comme
c'était tout à l'heure par Monsieur
Griset sur la collecte de
l'apprentissage la tax d'apprentissage
et àoir avec bien sûr comm on disait une
affectation obligatoire mais aussi le
dialogue dans dans le cadre des plans
régionaux de développement des
formations un débat avec les filières
professionnelles pour pouvoir ensuite
avoir un plan audacieux de
l'apprentissage si on ne fait pas ça on
se retrouvera dans 4 5 ans on fera les
mêmes constats ici et donc je le dis ça
quels que soient nos nos divergences ou
nos opinions politique on est devant un
problème structurel et pour légitimer
l'apprentissage pas seulement faire une
école de la deuxième chance en faire une
formation initiale à part entière et
bien nous devons prendre des des des
comment des des des directions
différentes et surtout simplifier c'est
quand même bien de dire que dans le plan
apprentissage il y a plus de problème
financiers c'est bien qu'on est devant
un problème culturel et si on est devant
un problème
empoignons-le puis
réglons-le bien alors on va terminer
avec Annique billon oui merci madame la
Présidente je vais être assez Brè je
pense qu'effectivement c'est intéressant
de s'enrichir de ce qui est fait à côté
surtout si ça marche moi sortir
l'éducation nationale c'est une des clés
que vous avez évoqué pour relancer
développer l'apprentissage donc je
rejoins mon collègue en lorsqu'il fait
référence à la difficulté de réformer
l'éducation nationale même jusqu'à aller
à sortir l'éducation nationale de
l'apprentissage et lorsque vous dites
monsieur ferrachci ferrachci oui qu'il
faut fléchir l'apprentissage sur les
premiers niveaux de formation donc vous
écartez un petit peu le supérieur c'est
valable pour effectivement lutter contre
le chômage des jeunes sans diplôme mais
comme le souligné un de mes collègues
tout à l'heure il y a aussi du chômage
de jeunes diplômés donc est-ce que
finalement ça serait peut-être opposer
le
supérieur au premier aux premières
formations on va dire et euh on a
tendance facilement en France déjà à
opposer systématiquement et on le voit
bien l'apprentissage n'est pas culturel
donc se dire que finalement on flèche
j'ai peut-être mal compris je vous vois
dire non on flèche plus précisément les
les premières les premiers degrés de
formation par rapport aux supérieurs
n'est-ce pas apporter de l'eau au moulin
à à la culture française qui oppose
systématiquement le supérieur à d'autres
formations et euh je voulais juste faire
référence France à tous nos travaux
qu'on a eu pendant toute cette année au
sein de la délégation aux entreprises et
on l'a bien vu dans les interventions on
a tendance nous politiques à
systématiquement vouloir apporter des
nouveaux outils les contrats jeunes les
contrats d'avenir et cetera en réalité
on a l'apprentissage et ben concentrons
nos efforts sur un outil et évitons de
nous disperser voilà merci très bien
merci alors monsieur ferrati je crois
que vous souhaitez répondre non je je je
je je je reviens un petit peu sur le sur
mes propos enfin pas pour pas pour les
contredire mais l'idée encore une fois
c'est pas de déshabiller Paul pour habit
et Pierre hein qu'on soit qu'on soit
bien clair
euh ce que le constat qu'on fait encore
une fois c'est que du point de vue de
l'efficacité de la dépense publique et
du point de vue de l'efficacité de la
dépense des entreprises du point de vue
de l'efficacité collective c'est plus
intéressant d'investir sur les apprentis
les moins qualifiés ça va jusqu'au bac
le cas échéant au bac professionnel euh
le fait que l'apprentissage est une
mauvaise image n'est pas ça je pense que
l'exemple allemand le souligne assez
n'est pas la conséquence du fait que il
y aurait des apprentis dans le dans
l'enseignement secondaire la preuve
c'est qu'en Allemagne il y a pas
d'apprentis dans le supérieur et que le
système a une très bonne image donc je
pense que l'enjeu ici n'est pas là
l'enjeu n'est pas forcément de rajouter
des moyens ça je souscris totalement à
ce qui été dit en revanche l'enjeu est
que toutes les sommes qui sont censées
financer l'apprentissage financent
effectivement l'apprentissage j'ai là je
je je suis totalement d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit par Monsieur Griset euh la
le problème du hors quota le problème de
ce dispositif qui permet de financer des
établissements de son choix lorsqu'on
est une entreprise sans forcément que ce
la finance des formations en
apprentissage et bien détourne une
partie des ressources et il se trouve
que ces ressources sont détournées euh
principalement des formations qui
pourraient s'adresser aux gens les moins
qualifiés donc je pense que pour être
très concret approfondir la réforme du
horcota comme ça a été initié par par la
loi Sapin de mars 2014 pour aller nous
on le préconise dans la note du Conseil
d'analise économique pour aller vers une
suppression pur et simple du he quota
c'est une voie vers laquelle il faut
aller et par ailleurs par ailleurs je
pense que il faut arriver encore une
fois à trouver des ressources pour
financer ces dispositifs de
préapprentissage dont il a été question
et auquel moi je crois beaucoup mais qui
sont extrêmement coûteux donc dans les
moyens qu'on a je pense qu'il faut faire
une réallocation des ressources sur des
dispositifs qui marchent euh et
particulièrement sur des dispositifs qui
sont à peu près les seuls permettant
d'insérer les jeunes les les jeunes les
jeunes sans diplôme voilà pour cette
table ronde dans le cadre des travaux de
la délégation aux entreprises présidées
par la sénatrice les républicains
Élisabeth Lamur table ronde consacré à
l'apprentissage et plus précisément au
recul de l'apprentissage on sait en 2014
il n'y a eu que
273000 nouveaux contrats d'apprentissage
c'est peu notamment si on compare ce
chiffre à celui de nos voisins européens
l'Allemagne par exemple où ce dispositif
est jugé très efficace et largement
choisi par les jeunes pour s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site sur publsenat.fr
prochain rendez-vous de l'actualité
parlementaire cet après-midi à 14h45
pour les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaire